Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w
unsere kleine welt mein name ist tim love und heute ist der fünfzehnte april zwanzig zwanzig ich hoffe ich kann mir mal merken das datum jetzt auch immer gleich am anfang.
Einzuwerfen denn so ganz unwichtig ist es ja nicht in diesen zeiten den kontext hier auch in der zeit zu setzen.
Ja und es ist mittwoch und das ist jetzt hier so ein bisschen unserer joa fix geworden mit pavel hallo pavel
ja wir wollen mal wieder zusammenfegen was ich denn eigentlich in der letzten woche so ergeben hat
insbesondere aber nicht nur was die ganzen zahlen die uns jetzt hier täglich um die ohren fliegen und durch,
timeline huschen und auf webseiten publiziert und in
gesprächen in funk und fernsehen einem so um die ohren geknallt werden.
Du warst wahrscheinlich wieder ganz fleißig und hast deine modelle gestreichelt.
Ja nicht ständig das ist halt sehr zeitaufwendig aber ja es ist mir halt
ein anliegen und ich versuche auch möglichst tagesaktuell
jeweils zumindest für mich zu gucken wie sich die zahlen entwickeln und dann so sag mal wenigstens einmal in der woche dann,
das ganze auch zumindest zu twittern oder ja hier mit dir zu besprechen.
Genau dann machen wir das doch einfach mal im vorgespräch ist uns
aufgefallen dass es auch zunehmenden maße schwierig wird den diskussionen zu folgen weil so viele begriffe in die welt gesetzt werden die wir bis vor kurzem noch überhaupt nicht so richtig kannten,
oder überhaupt nicht kannten ich frag mich jetzt inwiefern angemessen ist das gleich voran zu stellen oder wir einfach mal drauf achten sollten diese dann zu erläutern wenn sie denn aufkommen.
Ja fangen wir doch mit den zahlen aus deutschland an weil die wahrscheinlich die meisten hörer erstmal interessieren dürften
und da fangen wir an mit der verdoppelungs-aktion zeit das ist halt die zeit in der sich die gesamtzahl der infektion,
verdoppelt so da liegen wir jetzt bei fünfunddreißig komma zwei tagen aktuell.
Also bezahlen es wieder gemeint bestätigte infektion.
Genau die gesamtzahl der bestätigten infektionen und ich beziehe mich auch immer auf die zahlen vom robert koch institut so weil es gibt halt auch noch andere zahlen sammlungen aber das sind die.
Mit denen ich arbeite und ich habe zusätzlich jetzt auch noch sagen der verdoppelung des zweit.
Für die anzahl der verstorbenen ausgerechnet und da hinken wir halt ein bisschen hinterher die liegt jetzt bei dreizehn komma vier tagen im moment.
Und dann sonst zweiter wert der.
Über den wir auch schon gesprochen haben dass es die sogenannte produktionszeit die auch immer in aller munde ist und da ist es glaube ich vielleicht,
mal aufzuklären es gibt die sogenannte basis reproduktion das es,
der wert sagen wieviel ein infiziertes wieviel andere personen im durchschnitt schafft.
Anzustecken und.
Zwar bevor irgendwie immunität entsteht bevor das bekannt ist bevor es irgendwelche maßnahmen ergriffen werden.
Am anfang wieder wieder virus wie virulent der ist.
Genau also eine virus spezifische zahl.
Genau ja und dann natürlich geschieht.
Entweder dadurch dass leute sich infizieren und immun werden und dann sogenannte herden immunität entsteht also wo in großer anzahl über die hälfte der
personen dann einmal infiziert und damit immun
geworden sind und dann nimmt natürlich diese reproduktion ab weil es nicht mehr so viele gibt die auch infiziert
werden können und durch durch entsprechende maßnahmen auch und diese reproduktion zahl nennt sich halt netto reproduktion das ist die die jetzt eben immer weiter
sinkt hoffentlich und da gibt es jetzt
auch also da müssen wir jetzt etwas weiter ausholen weil ich wurde auch jetzt mehrfach gefragt so ja wie,
berechnet sich denn eigentlich diese netto produktionszeit aus den zahlen und wenn man jetzt sagen ok jetzt eine einfache formel angeben aber wenn man
sich das genauer anguckt stellt man fest das ist das steckt ein ganzer wust an dingen noch dahinter und,
es gibt auch eigentlich nicht die berechnung.
Methode sondern man kann es auf verschiedene arten berechnen.
Mit unterschiedlichen annahmen ich kann erst mal sagen ich bin jetzt herausgefunden wie das alles robert-koch-institut.
Die werte berechnet und zwar gehen die hin und nehmen erstmal an das.
Bei der ausbreitung,
ist eine generationshof zeit gibt oder englisch siri intervall von vier tagen so das heißt von
eine erkrankung ansteckung bis zur nächsten erkrankung des jeweils vier tage sind und dann.
Nehmen sie einfach die summe der neuen erkrankungen von heute minus acht tage bis heute minus vier tage,
und
teilen es durch die summe der neue erkrankung der letzten vier tage vier tage die summe vier tage die summe und dann jeweils die neue erkrankungen zusammengezählt und dann durcheinander geteilt.
Zusätzlich kommt aber noch das problem,
dazu dass das das ganze nicht auf basis der.
Gemeldeten also veröffentlichten gesamtzahlen berechnet sondern,
versuchen das etwas genauer auf das melde datum oder erkrankung datum zu rechnen da haben sie aber das problem dass halt die meldungen
teilweise verspätet eintreffen das heißt manchmal ein zwei drei tage später erst oder vier tage bekommt dann
eine meldung rein die dann sozusagen das melde datum beim gesundheitsamt oder das erkrankungen datum entsprechend zurückliegt so dass sie
gar nicht wenn wenn sie diese zahlen nehmen.
Gar nicht in den aktuellen wert berechnen können sondern den immer nur eine woche später berechnen können den wert so das zweite problem ist dass das,
was grob ist diese methode wenn man die zahlen so direkt nimmt.
Und da ergibt sich dann nämlich etwas sehr unschönes man stellt nämlich fest und das schrieb,
auch das in seinem bolton dass die reproduktion unter eins gefallen ist was ja
eins ist dieser wichtige wert wo die neue erkrankung zurückgehen und dann aber wieder angestiegen ist so schreiben die dass ich
ich habe da meine zweifel so dass es tatsächlich so gelaufen ist
möglich wäre es aber wenn man sich das ganze anguckt so den den kurven fall auf wenn man genau diese diese berechnung macht.
Dann stellt man fest dass diese kurve runtergeht aber im wochenrückblick mus auch,
schwingt und dass die anstiege dann halt kommen natürlich wenn das ganze sich gerade in einem aufschwung befindet und im moment sind wir gerade in einem abschwung.
So das heißt gerade tag heute nach der ungefilterten methode
beträgt die netto reproduktion gerade null komma fünf vier wir sind also gerade unglaublich weit unten also es muss das schreiben so in demselben duktus ja und dann
viel diese netto reproduktion zahl aber extrem ab in den in den letzten tagen so.
Ich glaube nicht dass das die richtige interpretation ist wobei die.
Tatsächlich offene frage ist schwankt die.
Produktionszeit möglicherweise wirklich im wochenende rassismus oder sind es alles datenerhebung artefakte weil die gesundheitsämtern am wochenende anders arbeiten oder die leute
am wochenende ja nicht zum arzt gehen oder so oder was auch eine möglichkeit wäre dass ich,
am wochenende vielleicht mehr leute infizieren als in der woche oder umgekehrt das weiß man nicht so genau
es wäre interessant dem mal nachzugehen ist aber ganz ganz schwierig dadurch dass halt auch durch diese erhebung schwankungen dass sie auch im wochenbett mus stattfinden.
Aber ich werde.
Versuchen den mal ein bisschen noch weiter nachzugehen aber dass es fand ich auf jeden fall ganz ganz spannend ich.
Benutze halt meine gefütterten daten das heißt ich rechne halt auf einem idealisierten geglättete pfad oder eine geglättete kurve
und komme dann glaube ich auf die realistische zahl von
null komma sieben fünf grade für die netto reproduktion in.
Also null komma sieben fünf für diese zahl würde im prinzip bedeuten dass jetzt so aus vier infizierten drei infizierte folgen.
Ja
könnte man sagen oder genau das das zehn infizierte siebeneinhalb verifiziert nach vier tagen hervorbringen,
allerdings außer jetzt auch noch sagen dass diese methode einfach sagen die vier ein vier tage durch die anderen vier tage.
Zu teilen jetzt nicht wirklich identisch mit der definition
derer produktionszeit ist weil wie gesagt die definition bezieht sich ja auf die frage wie viel.
Schafft es jemand anzustecken und nicht wie viele stecken sich in vier tagen.
An sozusagen durch vier tage und da habe ich dann nochmal versucht ein bisschen genauer an der definition zu rechnen indem ich aus der zahl der,
infizierten versucht hab raus der infektiösen so also der ansteckenden rauszurechnen,
da habe ich nämlich im prinzip die zahl der ansteckenden heute geteilt durch die zahl der ansteckenden vor vier tagen also spielt auch die generationshof zeit mit rein
und jetzt ist die frage okay wie kommt man auf die zahl der ansteckenden da muss man wiederum zwei weitere annahmen treffen nämlich
von wann bis wann nach der ansteckung jemand ansteckend ist und da gibt es halt,
auf verschiedene zahlen und da muss man sich dann auf einen intervall festlegen ich habe jetzt sagen das intervall am dritten tag wird jemand im schnitt
ansteckend und ist dann bis zum etwa dreizehn komma fünften tag nachdem er sich infiziert hat also.
Das ist von ansteckung bis nicht mehr infektiös ungefähr vierzehn tage sind so.
Also also zehn tage wo man effektiv ansteckend ist in einem zeitraum von zwei wochen.
Genau zehn komma fünf tage wurde ist die zahl die ich auch auf der seite in dem steckbrief gefunden habe so,
das führt.
Im prinzip zu einem ähnlichen ergebnis allerdings zeitversetzt also das
führt dazu dass die zu einem späteren zeitpunkt erst sinkt ungefähr eine
eine woche oder so und das führt dann dazu wenn ich das nach der methode nach der ansteckenden methode berechne,
dann sind es null komma acht sieben.
Als produktionszeit siebenundachtzig prozent so man sieht also jetzt schon dass mit diesem,
produktionszeit zahlen ist so ein bisschen nur so eine halbwegs exakte
wissenschaft und je nachdem wie man da rechnet und wie man da fällt hat kommt man jetzt zu drei völlig verschiedenen reproduktion zahlen für heute.
Also siebenundachtzig prozent ist jetzt sozusagen das was du für jetzt gerade aktiv geltend ausgerechnet hast.
Das wäre sagen nach nach einer methode so die vielleicht
realistisch ist vielleicht nicht die aber mehr annahmen hat ansonsten
ja wie gesagt nach der methode aber gefiltert und ohne diese wöchentlichen schwankungen,
eben bei null komma sieben fünf und haut man die zahlen direkt rein bei null komma fünf vier.
Also man könnte zumindest mal festhalten es ist relativ wahrscheinlich dass derzeit weniger leute angesteckt werden.
Als als richtig formuliert nein also das das die ansteckung zurückgehen auf jeden fall,
tragen das virus auf jeden fall nicht mehr so weit wie es eigentlich könnte und die maßnahmen dagegen sind zumindest soweit gedient in deutschland
dass wenn das jetzt so weiterläuft die zahl der infizierten immer weiter zurück gehen würde.
Gesetz man würde diesen zustand so beibehalten können was wir wahrscheinlich so nicht können zumindest nicht dauerhaft.
Ja aber im im moment genau sind wir geht es geht es zurück und.
Vielleicht ganz konkret jetzt zu den zahlen,
vielleicht erstmal was wir so vor einer woche prognostiziert haben bei einer vor einer woche am siebten vierten,
damals standen stand der wert bei neunundneunzig tausendzweihundert fünfundzwanzig gesamtinvestition und.
Die prognose für wo es hin läuft am ende also wo es sich stabilisiert.
Bei hundertfünfzigtausend mit einer spannbreite von hundertzwanzig bis hundertsechzig tausend und.
So für die zahl der toten war es noch sehr schwierig weil die schwanken immer noch sehr stark,
aber ja da sind wir jetzt aktuell ist die,
aktualisierte prognose eher viertausend bis neuntausend mit wahrscheinlich im moment fünftausend wo es hin zeigt und die,
sagen die prognose aber wo es bei den gesamt zahlen hinläuft,
hat sich nicht wesentlich verändert also hundertfünfzigtausend hat mir gesagt vor einer woche und aktuell auf hundert dreiundfünfzigtausend läuft es hinaus.
Warum haben wir jetzt in etwa dieselbe vorhersage für infektionen aber eine höhere toten zahl.
Weil ich die kurven das sind halt zwei verschiedene,
werte die sich unterschiedlich entwickeln so und wo sich unterschiedliche kurven raus ergeben und eine sache ist die sterblichkeit
steigt halt derzeit an da kommen wir auch noch
hin zu dem thema und bei den toten sind wir noch in einem punkt der kurve gewesen vor einer woche wo man eigentlich noch nicht so richtig viel sagen konnte.
Aus der kurve alleine heraus das heißt da ist die die fehlerquote noch groß und die ist auch immer noch gesagt sehr groß sogar größer geworden jetzt wieder weil.
In der letzten woche die die die zahlen bei den toten doch sehr stark geschwankt haben.
Also könnte auch noch alles viel schlimmer werden.
Ja könnte alles also schlimmer geht immer so
aber es sieht im moment nicht danach aus sondern es sieht im moment danach aus dass wir am ende um die fünftausend landen werden wie gesagt bei den toten und hundertfünfzigtausend euro hundert dreiundfünfzigtausend bei den gesamten.
Bedeutet denn das jetzt darauf hin dass schon irgend ein wendepunkt erreicht ist oder ist das alles noch total unklar.
Nein also wenn du punkte haben wir definitiv wie gesagt beim zahl der der neue infektion schon lange und bei
bei der zahl der der toten haben wir auch den höhepunkt hinter uns
was man im moment noch nicht so genau sagen kann ist wie das mit der auslastung von unserem gesundheitssystem
aussieht,
da sollten wir eigentlich mittlerweile auch über den berg sein aber die einzigen zahlen die wir hier haben nämlich aus dem diva intensiv register die schwanken halt
täglich sehr stark weil man eine unterschiedliche zahl von krankenhäusern meldet und
aber die quote wenn man immer berechnet okay wieviel intensivbetten sind jetzt von patienten belegt im vergleich zum
gemeldeten gesamtbild angebot dann bewegt sich diese zahl seit längerem also immer nicht geguckt habe war die irgendwo zwischen elf und zwölf prozent also da hat sich nichts bewegt
aber es ist halt unklar ob wir über den berg sind klar ist nur die zahlen nehmen nicht wesentlich zu und sie nehmen nicht wesentlich ab.
Das kann man aus den aus diesen zahlen letztlich entnehmen aber mehr auch nicht.
Ok aber gewisse stabilität der situation lässt sich sozusagen daraus ablesen in meine was man ja wenig hört ist jenseits der ohnehin schon vorhandenen überforderung des gesundheitswesens
kommt sozusagen die krankenhauslandschaft mit dem mit der kugel neunzehn belastung derzeit noch gut zurecht.
Es wird kapazität freigeschaufelt haben wir ja auch schon drüber gesprochen es werden teilweise auch ganz neue locations eröffnet um da noch mehr puffer zu schaffen und eine überlastung gibt es
regional hier und da aber nicht in einem maße dass man jetzt schon italienische verhältnisse hätte.
Nee da sind wir nach wie vor ein bis zwei wochen enden ungebremsten wachstum
entfernt was wir aber nicht mehr haben das heißt wenn man jetzt sagt diese zwölf prozent das ist etwa eine größenordnung die wir hätten bewältigen können
ohne betten frei zu machen und ohne zusätzliche betten zu schaffen wahrscheinlich.
Also dann wären wir aber voll gewesen durch den betten frei machen und
zusätzliche betten schaffen sind aktuell viermal so viele betten frei wie wir aktuell cockpit patienten.
Haben das heißt wir haben sozusagen faktor vier sicherheit aber eben bei exponentiellem wachstum also so wie wir das am anfang hatten.
Bedeutet dass wir waren halt zwei wochen vom zusammenbruch unseres gesundheitssystems entfernt.
So hätten wir zwei wochen später erst maßnahmen eingeführt kann man sagen ja hätten wir italienische verhältnisse.
Eine woche später hätten wir gerade noch
so geschafft aber um den preis von ungefähr viermal so so vielen zahlen also viermal so hohen werten bei
toten und bei erkrankten und dann wäre alles am anschlag so das heißt man kann sagen
so die maßnahmen kamen definitiv nicht zu früh.
Hallo.
Definitiv nicht so früh.
Das ist doch mal eine ganz gute aussage so also ja erstaunlich.
So und hätten wir noch eine woche früher wäre es noch eine woche früher gewesen hätte man die ausschläge gar nicht gemerkt bei den bei den patienten zahlen.
Also wäre sozusagen auch durchaus angemessen gewesen noch früher zu reagieren.
Also.
Ja doch kann man sagen wenn wir eine woche früher reagiert hätten also es ist auch so das wird nochmal interessant sein zu rechnen weil der die verlangsamung
also sagen das bremsen
dauert länger als das beschleunigen so also unser motor ist halt stärker ist unsere bremsen oder der der motor vom virus können halt schneller beschleunigen als abbremsen so,
das heißt wenn wir jetzt eine woche früher gebremst hätten,
hätte das unsere bremsstreifen deutlich mehr als um eine woche verkürzt
vermutlich ich hab's jetzt nicht gerechnet werden ich aber vielleicht mal für die für die nächste sendung machen ich würde mal schätzen so,
eine woche früher gestartet hätte bedeutet zwei wochen früher aufhören.
Ungefähr ein faktor von eins eins zu zu zwei also.
Also es hätte uns zumindest erkaufen können das jetzt alles sehr hypothetisch aber es hätte uns vermutlich kürzere maßnahmen beschert.
Das hätte uns ja wieviel weiß man nicht aber doch größenordnungsmäßigen glaube ich könnte das könnte das so so hinkommen sagen dass
eine woche früher
anfangen zwei wochen kürzere brems zeit also insgesamt drei wochen früher raus in in absoluter zeit.
Hallo.
Anbetracht des schönen wetters wäre das ja ganz wünschenswert gewesen.
Ja
Und natürlich vor allem auch was halt die auswirkungen auf die wirtschaft betrifft weil wir haben ja jetzt im prinzip nur die auswirkungen auf das gesundheitssystem beleuchtet und natürlich ist das natürlich hier überhaupt auch das riesenthema
insbesondere was jetzt eben die aufhebung also die diskussion um die aufhebung der ganzen maßnahmen betrifft.
Während man könnte es wahrscheinlich sogar ein geld beziffern so werden wahrscheinlich hundertfünfzig milliarden ungefähr mindestens an weniger an verlusten gewesen wenn wir eine woche früher angefangen hätten.
Da hätte man schon ein paar spielplätze von bauern können.
Bevor wir vielleicht diese auf was ist das jetzt erstmal angemessen die diskussion um diese aufhebung aufzugreifen oder hast du dir auch noch andere länder angeschaut die wir uns vorher nochmal anschauen sollten.
Ja ich ich gucke mir ja immer so zum zum vergleich und auch um zu sehen.
Ist das fechten pfad auf dem wir uns uns auch bewegen gucke ich mir halt die usa und china und italien immer mit an.
Und da vielleicht einen einen kurzes update also die usa hat heute etwas über sechshunderttausend,
infizierte und sechsundzwanzigtausend tote und,
thema sterblichkeit
ja da kommt kommen wir ja noch noch zu aber genau das verdopplung rate von fünfzehneinhalb tagen bei den infektionen die es so deutlich zurückgegangen da merkt man jetzt auch schon
im moment.
Sie zahlen zumindest gehen gerade zurück wobei sie frage ist auch sind es melde artefakte vielleicht oder gehen die wirklich zurück und bei den toten zehn komma vier tage
verdoppelungs-aktion hatte also da ist es auch ganz gut zurückgegangen
das ist ganz erfreulich wenn sich das so bestätigen sollte wobei ich noch nicht so ganz dran glaube.
Weil ja also wenn man es mit italien vergleicht also ich habe halt immer mal geguckt wenn,
sich ein land in der größenordnung von sieben oder acht tagen,
sterblichkeit ja verdopplung der der toten befunden hat wo ist es denn dann hinterher rausgelaufen
und das war doch schon eher dann nochmal zwischen dem zwei und vierfachen von von dem sodass
ja man in den usa jetzt aber mit einer erfreulichen gesamtzahl von wahrscheinlich vierzig bis achtzigtausend toten rechnen kann wenn.
Ja wenn da jetzt in den aktuellen zahlen nicht irgendwo der der wurm drin ist und,
ja mit einer gesamtziel infektionsbad prognose für die usa dass sie irgendwo zwischen siebenhundertfünfzigtausend und eins komma eins millionen in der spitze
rauskommen werden da sie haben wahrscheinlich so etwas über die hälfte vielleicht zwei drittel der gesamtinvestition geschafft wenn sie
weiter aus auf der bremse bleiben und es nicht jetzt vielleicht irgendwo in ländern also in ja
jetzt bundesländern der der usa.
Irgendwo bis zu neu ausbrüchen kommt wo kein shutdown herrscht so was aber nicht zu erwarten ist.
Was ist denn da deine deine datenquelle bei den usa.
Bei wikipedia da werden die daten ganz gut
aggregiert und da kann ich die halt direkt per dann von der website per copy paste mir immer die zwei eins zwei drei,
neuen werte rauskopieren weil da lohnt sich im moment nicht bei den systemen mit denen ich denen ich arbeite
kompletten daten import zu machen aus irgendeiner anderen quelle zumal ich dann immer gucken muss.
So sind es überhaupt neuere zahlen die auf plausibilität prüfen und so also.
Da fällt mir ein das wäre ja mal ein ganz gutes feature request für die wikipedia dass man einfach mal generell daten in jeder tabelle die sie haben einfach direkt in der webseite auch mal als csv runterladen könnte also so,
immer das sollte ja so schwierig eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Ja denke ich auch ja und.
Bei der reproduktionsmedizinischen in den usa wenn ich das sagt nach der methode sind die bei null komma neun drei also auch unter eins bereits.
Nach meiner infizierten methode sind sie allerdings noch bei eins komma eins im moment.
Vorausgesetzt die zahlen stimmen auch überhaupt also ich habe da ja so ein bisschen meine zweifel wenn man sich so das gesundheitssystem in den usa anschaut dass da überhaupt einfach alles erfasst wird was was was stattfindet.
Ist ganz schwer zu sagen im im moment wobei.
Man das gesundheitssystem der usa auch nicht unterschätzen sollte so auch wenn es vielleicht ein bisschen ungleich verteilt ist geben die halt doch extrem viel geld,
aus für gesundheitssystem und,
sind eigentlich ärzte und klinik mäßig nicht so schlecht ausgestattet sondern im gegenteil.
Ja ich mache das auch gar nicht so sehr in bezug auf die ausstattung das ist sicherlich dann aber halt hat mir auch schon paar mal angesprochen einfach die problematik dass es eben für viele leute so teuer ist.
Sich auch nur ein krankenhaus zu nähern da sieht man dass ich einfach die vermutung habe das.
Einfach viele fälle überhaupt nicht gesehen werden ja und dann auch nicht gezählt werden und das einfach da auch vielleicht viele leute an sterben ohne.
Überhaupt für kurvis gezählt zu werden.
Wobei am ende wird man das halt sehen können wenn irgendwie die gesamtstaatlichen zeit
zahlen da sind wobei da gibt's glaube ich durchaus auch schon wer ich weiß noch nicht wie aktuell die sind aber so richtig weiß man denn es wahrscheinlich um die ersten einen monat später oder so wenn man dann die
die zahlen hat wie viele leute insgesamt überhaupt gestorben sind und dann kann man rückschlüsse ziehen ob es dann ein wie groß der effekt
ist und ob der in den maßen sich bewegt wie man sich das gedacht hat oder nicht,
vielleicht ja vielleicht ganz kurz zu china da hat sich nicht wesentlich was geändert da,
dümpeln die infektion immer noch vor sich hin da gab's irgendwie entweder ist gestern niemand gestorben oder es wurde niemand gemeldet
dafür gab's schon heute sagen die doppelte zahl vermutlich ge war das einfach ein eine melde-app fakt aber die china bewegt sich so bei dreißig neuinfektionen am tag größenordnung,
jetzt schon seit einer ganzen weile.
Und eröffnet jetzt wieder speziell in wo wo hahn woher der großteil der infektion war,
italien das interessante bei italien ist die haben zwar sind jetzt auch über den berg und haben eine verdopplung
rate jetzt auch von ja neununddreißig tagen bei den bei den infektionen so zum vergleich wir sind bei fünfunddreißig tagen
und haben aber.
Interessant hohe reproduktion zahl da komme ich auf je nach dem wie ich das rechne auf achtzig bis siebenundachtzig prozent also null komma acht eins bis null komma acht sieben
je nach berechnungsmethode
ja das fand ich so ein bisschen überraschend hoch im vergleich jetzt auch zu deutschland oder oder speziell zur china die halt richtig tief
runter sind so china liegt bei null komma fünf.
Zumal ja die maßnahmen in italien ja auch ziemlich hart waren und noch sind.
Ziemlich hart waren und sinn und trotzdem
zieht sich das ganze ganz schön hin in italien muss man sagen es geht da ziemlich zäh runter gerade ich hoffe ja nicht dass das bei uns sich auch so zäh gestalten wird.
Hast du da irgendeine erklärung dafür also gibt's da irgendwas was ich da weil wenn ich das so hier mir anschaue dann ist es in der tat.
Die abschwächung ist langsamer in italien da ist spanien schon weiter und die haben ja ähnliche maßnahmen ergriffen und ja würde ich auch sagen auch ähnliche rahmenbedingungen.
Ein bisschen schwer das zu vergleichen aber so.
Klimatisch ähnlich ähnliche probleme im gesundheitssystem et cetera also irgendwas irgendwas läuft da noch noch noch quer in italien das wird man wahrscheinlich erst später beurteilen können.
Es kann halt sein was was immer sein kann was sich so zahlen verändert.
Wenn sich infektion sagen von einer,
altersgruppe oder betroffene gruppe in eine andere ausbreiten so dann ändert sich natürlich dann plötzlich auch die sterblichkeit und eventuell auch wie viele leute sich überhaupt anstecken,
aber in italien hieß es ja von anfang an oh es sind vor allem alte leute betroffen das heißt es hätte eigentlich eher nur schneller besser werden
müssen und nicht sich so langsam dahin ziehen andere sache könnte sein dass die italiener vielleicht wirklich auf die maßnahmen pfeifen.
Oder ist da irgendwie noch andere unentdeckte
italien spezifische übertragungswagen gibt die noch niemand auf dem schirm hat aber alles in allem finde ich die finde ich das schon bemerkenswert die also c das in italien zurück geht.
Ja das wären sozusagen die sachen die ich was was das ausland angeht,
beizutragen hätte.
Jetzt haben wir diese debatte mit der wiedereröffnung gehabt da gab es ja dann auch diese studie die extrem unter feuer gekommen ist die in gangelt.
Durchgeführt wurde in nordrhein-westfalen in diesem bereich heinzberg der ja
hat mir auch schon mehrfach hier beleuchtet durch diese karnevalssitzung zu der zeit sich eine extreme infektion,
eingefangen hat heinzberg muss man dazu sagen und gange das ist halt so am äußersten ende also ist glaube ich sogar fast der.
Es ist glaube ich so ziemlich der der westlichste punkt deutschlands wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Bin ich mir noch gar nicht angeguckt.
Kein hinhauen also sozusagen von berlin auf jeden fall sehr weit weg und da ist halt jetzt so eine forschergruppe reingegangen.
Logo und haben dann mal sehr umfangreich getestet und haben halt in in gange in diesem ort.
Sehr viele leute getestet und die studie dann auch schon.
So auf halbem wege vor veröffentlicht also ich glaube die haben irgendwie tausend leute.
Getestet und nachdem sie kurz über fünfhundert waren haben sie sich da eben schon in die öffentlichkeit getraut das ja jetzt auch schon medien weit berichtet worden und vor allem gab es ja ein riesen
ein riesen aufreger um diese zahlen wahrhafter auf der einen seite das eben auch schon so vermutet wurde dass das jetzt sozusagen,
okay jetzt haben wir hier mal geguckt dann ist ja alles gar nicht so schlimm da kann man ja auch wieder aufmachen und dann gab es aber relativ viel gegenwind weil eben,
diesen veröffentlichten zahlen viele parameter fehlten also ich habe da sehr viel skepsis gelesen allen voran hat sich natürlich auch der trosten dazu geäußert und dann gab es da viel hin und her
kernproblem glaube ich nehmen so ein paar anderen problemen war das einfach die ganze statistische bewertung dieser zahlen schwierig war,
schlicht weil solche sachen wie es wurden dann alle.
Mitglieder eines haushalts getestet und es ist natürlich klar dass wenn einer im haushalt den virus hat das
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass andere das auch haben relativ hoch ist
und dann fehlten halt entsprechende gewichtungen wie wir das jetzt sozusagen in das statistische modell eingeflochten ist ne was ist wenn das jetzt ein großer haushalt mit vielen leuten ist das natürlich klar dass ich dann mehr ansteckend beziehungsweise was es mit kleinen haushalten etcetera p p
kann das alles nicht beurteilen weil es so zahlen kram die ich mir wieder genau angeschaut habe noch den ich jetzt konkret statistisch mathematisch in irgendeiner form,
bewerten kann aber merkt auf jeden fall die nervosität steigt.
Und solche zahlen werden jetzt in zunehmenden maße herangezogen um die ein oder andere agenda und vorschlags präferenz zu.
Unterstützen.
So das problem so ein bisschen was ich hatte mit der studie war dass ich sie auch diese studie nicht finden konnte das halt sehr viel darüber geredet wurde hast du irgendwo einen link
oder so zu dieser studie gefunden weil
also ja genauso zu der ersten heinzberg studie wo er,
strikt ja auch ganz viel drüber erzählt hat und da auch ganz viel diskutiert wurde konnte ich dort auch
die studie nicht finden auch keine vor veröffentlichung oder so aber es wurden eine ganze reihe von zahlen.
Bei pressekonferenzen und so dort genannt und.
Unter anderem eben eine legalität von null komma drei sieben prozent also eine sterblichkeit so dazu muss man jetzt vielleicht noch sagen
bei sterblichkeit unterscheidet man.
Zunächst mal zwischen wie es das nennt fall verstorbenen anteil oder im englischen case verteidigt y rate oder c f l das sind die zahlen die ich vorhin
auch genannt habe so im zusammenhang mit der aktuellen.
Sterblichkeit also gesagt in deutschland zwei komma fünf prozent gerade und wird wahrscheinlich am ende auf drei komma drei prozent hinauslaufen
so jetzt aber eine legalität das ist sozusagen der anteil wieviel.
Wieviel von den infizierten eigentlich jetzt sterben das ist digitalität oder und da soll bei der heinzberg studio null komma drei sieben prozent bei rausgekommen
sein so wenn das so stimmen würde und man das jetzt auf deutschland.
Übertragen könnte so die gesamtzahl dann würde das bedeuten dass sich ungefähr mal acht neun mal,
so viele menschen infiziert haben wie wir bisher glauben so.
Also wenn man sozusagen die aktuellen gestorbenen zahlen nimmt und die.
Genau.
Annimmt dass das null komma drei prozent dann müsste es neun mal mehr infizierte geben als wir derzeit zählen.
Genau so weil man das halt entsprechend hoch rechnen kann
und das wäre halt schon krass so weil dann nämlich sagen schon deutlich mehr leute sich sich infiziert hätten also dann würde das
das thema herden immunität wäre da nicht
ganz so weit weg ich meine es ist trotzdem noch noch weit weg also das würde bedeuten dass wir bis es sich bisher eine million menschen tatsächlich infiziert haben statt der
was hatten wir jetzt hundert.
Hundertdreißig waren wir jetzt ja genau und.
Man rechnet eigentlich damit dass die tatsächliche zahl so ungefähr doppelt so hoch ist.
Wie man jetzt erfasst hat dass da spricht halt auch einiges für und da klafft natürlich eine gewaltige lücke also ob wir jetzt
zweihundertsechzigtausend oder zwischen zweihundert und dreihunderttausend tatsächlich infizierte oder über eine million haben das macht natürlich schon
ein unterschied und was ich jetzt mal versucht habe rauszufinden wie plausibel ist denn das und es gab,
als schon andere studien zum beispiel auf den kreuzfahrtschiff diamond princess hatte man.
Auch hat man alle leute getestet und da sind bei der diamond princess.
Hatte ich neulich auch mal gerechnet aber größer mich wenn ich siebenhundert leute in energy gegend erkrankt.
Zwölf verstorben und dementsprechend.
Konnte man dann auch also gibt es gibt es auch eine studie die die ist aber ein bisschen zu alt,
schon die gehen da die hatten noch nicht alle verstorbenen zahlen und die zahlen sind eigentlich auch sehr klein aber auf jeden fall wie man es dreht oder wendet eine so geringe vitalität,
hat sich bisher nirgendwo gefunden also in keiner der der schiffs studien oder anderen
studien sodass insofern wäre das schon eine sensation aber die große frage ist die tatsächlich die übertragbaren zeit
und am ende war es natürlich wissen wenn antikörper tests da sind und da laufen wir jetzt auch untersuchungen also in bayern läuft jetzt noch eine ähnliche studie und.
Ich glaube also wir werden irgendwann bescheid wissen aber im moment.
Ist die zahl ja die zahlen null komma drei sieben erscheint mir selbst wenn sie stimmt wahrscheinlich nicht auf deutschland übertragbar.
Also wenn man die zahlen von der damen princess mal nimmt also da waren ja dreitausendsechshundert leute an bord zwölf leute sind gestorben während alle infiziert gewesen dann werden diese zwölf tatsächlich diese null komma drei prozent in etwa.
Null komma drei drei habe ich gerade mal nachgerechnet ja da aber nur siebenhundertzwölf sich infiziert hatten oder zumindest,
bei siebenhundertzwölf infektion nachgewiesen wurde ist ja auch noch mal eine frage wie gut das funktioniert ne selbst wenn man nochmal ein paar rein rechnet also bei bei siebenhundertzwölf machen die zwölf leute halt,
eins komma sechs acht prozent aus.
Genau das heißt das sind so eher also das kann man sagen das war die größenordnung jetzt auf dem schiff und da muss man auch mal sehen sind,
der altersanzug teil.
Mehr in richtung alt verschoben das heißt wenn man jetzt auf dem bevölkerungs querschnitt umrechnet kann man da auch noch ein bisschen was abziehen.
Und die ist natürlich auch alle viel näher beieinander also die treffen sich ja dann meine dreitausendsechshundert leute auf dem schiff da treffen sich halt sind die leute sicher auch viel näher die sind beim essen zusammen die sind ne also
etcetera du hast da enge verhältnisse also repräsentativ ist es auch nicht.
Nicht nicht nicht wirklich aber gut entweder infiziert sich jemand oder jemand infiziert sich nicht
so kann man jetzt sagen aber klar es.
Also verläufe und wie wie stark die anfangs infektion war wie viel sagen wir in kopien jemand abbekommen hat.
Das kann natürlich sehr stark variieren da auf dem schiff und jetzt in gangelt oder heinzberg oder.
Ja also.
Mein eindruck so ich konnte nirgendwo bisher eine derart niedrige vitalität finden außer in dieser studie.
Sondern eher alle anderen angaben zur digitalität lagen.
Deutlich höher so eher also unter einem prozent war da nichts eins komma zwei oder so war glaube ich das niedrigste was ich bisher gefunden hatte an jetzt.
Gerechnet auf dem bevölkerungsdurchschnitt.
Und ich meine auch dann gibt's da relativ wenig zu bejubeln also selbst wenn es weiter null komma drei sieben prozent läge null komma sieben prozent von deutschland.
Sind auch irgendwie so knapp dreihunderttausend leute also es ist jetzt nichts wo man jetzt befreit in den park rennt.
Nein aber es wäre insofern eine gute nachricht dass sagen die gefahr wenn man sich ansteckt.
Dann doch niedriger wäre,
also insofern wäre das schon also sozusagen wenn die sterblichkeit deutlich niedriger wäre wäre das eigentlich eine gute,
sache also wäre schon also so oder so positiv aber sagt meiner meinung nach
lassen sich die zahlen nicht auf ganz deutschland ohne weiteres übertragen hat glaube ich auch niemand behauptet,
aber ja versuchen kann man's ja trotzdem mal ja.
Was ich auch noch gemacht habe so plausibilität tests man kann ja.
Versuchen auch hochzurechnen die die zahl der infizierten aus der zahl der verstorbenen wenn man.
Einfach eine bestimmte feste sterblichkeitsrate annimmt was,
in der wirklichkeit halt auch nicht so ist weil die tatsächlich glaube ich schwankt je nachdem ob
das jetzt gerade mehr in altersheimen grassiert oder in schulen um das mal auf ein auf den punkt zu bringen
hast du halt ja eine ganz unterschiedliche gesamtstaatliche zeit aber
mir ist es eigentlich ganz gut gelungen sagen die sterblichkeitsrate kurve auf die infizierten kurve,
zu
Übertragen da gibt's jetzt nicht so gewaltige abweichungen also insofern mein was ich wozu ich das getan habe war halt zu gucken,
sagen wie wie sind die kurven wie verhält wie sind die zeitlich zueinander verschoben weil der höhepunkt bei einer quote der verstorbenen kommt natürlich später als der höhepunkt,
bei der.
Die zahl der infizierten und man kann das jetzt auch nicht so ohne weiteres bei diesen starken schwankungen die wir haben nicht so ohne weiteres aus den aus den zahlen
direkt entnehmen also man kann das kann das ungefähr schätzen und aber ihr seid grundsätzlich passt das ist plausibel aber,
hilft halt jetzt nicht die digitalität tatsächlich zu.
Berechnen sondern auch da kommt man nur auf den den den fall verstorbenen anteil und.
Der unterschied ist eben nur
dass die verschätzt quote bei den verstorbenen wahrscheinlich eine andere ist als die verschmutzung quote bei bei der messung der der infizierten und
man kann aber engere grenzen bei der zahl der verstorbenen setzen als bei der zahl der infizierten weil die infizierten könnten sich theoretisch schon die hälfte der republik infiziert haben.
Auf der anderen seite aus den tests also wir wissen ja.
Wiederum aus den tests das so zwischen nur zwischen fünf und zehn prozent der getesteten tatsächlich positiv auf corvette getestet wurden und das obwohl.
Ja nur verdachts person also leute mit symptomen und die kontakt hatten oder aus.
Risikogebieten kam nur nur die wurden ja getestet und.
Insofern wäre also so eine hohe quote von einer million ich muss das nochmal nachrechnen.
Also ich bin da ich bin da ich bin da dran ich hatte hatte das auch schon mal also wie man es dreht und und und wendet übertragung auf deutschland so ohne weiteres nicht möglich,
aber vielleicht,
könnte es sein dass in deutschland halt tatsächlich die sterblichkeit dann doch etwas geringer ist als wir es als als wir es bisher vermutet hatten.
Ja die ja auch mit der gesundheitsversorgung was zu tun hat ne also natürlich sterben mehr leute wenn man sich sind nicht ordentlich um sie kümmern kann ja wenn sie dann eine chance gehabt hätten aber diese chance eben nicht erhalten dann wird sich das natürlich auch entsprechend auswirken.
Ja wobei da die unterschiede so gewaltig nicht sind wenn man sich anguckt wie viele
menschen in den ländern auf der intensivstation sterben und wie viele geheilt sind war es in italien glaube ich so ungefähr halbe halbe.
Aktuelle zahl jetzt jetzt nicht im kopf aber eher also näher bei halbe halbe werden's in deutschland ungefähr nur ein drittel bisher verstorben ist derer die auf der intensivstation sind aber
das ist halt auch nur eine momentaufnahme.
Dann lass uns doch zum abschluss nochmal vielleicht den blick auf.
Europa werfen wir haben ja jetzt im prinzip nur über die länder gesprochen die du jetzt selber auch nachrichten nest ja auch,
immer noch die allgemeinen zahlen wo sich besonders schlecht zu entwickeln scheint derzeit ist.
Also wenn ich mir so die dreieck theorie da anschaue diese noch das steigert sich das irgendwie alles noch habe ich so den eindruck.
Ja das sieht da da ist noch absolut keine entwarnung angesagt das sieht nicht gut aus,
bei italien ist mir auch noch eine sache aufgefallen gerade als ich.
Nochmal verglichen hatte in italien
ziehen in den letzten tagen die zahlen eigentlich nach oben raus
so also gegenüber dem wie sie eigentlich hätten verlaufen sollen wenn die maßnahmen beibehalten worden wären also in italien sieht es so aus entweder als wenn die leute vielleicht
schon bisschen quarantäne überdrüssig sind und angefangen haben unvorsichtiger zu werden oder irgendwas anderes
sich da tut aber italien entwickelt sich nicht schön muss man sagen,
und ja und england so.
Oder united kingdom ja da kann man im moment fast nur beten dass das irgendwie.
Dort auch schleunigst jetzt mal sich verlangsamt.
Zumal sie auch extrem hohe zahlen bei den toten haben sie sind jetzt irgendwie bei bei zwölftausend
im vergleich zu knapp fünfundneunzigtausend gemeldeten infizierten wir sind ja meine infizierten zahlen schon viel viel viel weiter aber nicht ansatzweise in diesem,
bei diesen toten zahlen angekommen.
Das ist in der tat auch so ein bisschen mysterium beziehungsweise,
eigentlich deutet so eine hohe zahl also so eine so eine hohe fallstelle zeit,
deutet er daraufhin dass es eine wesentlich höheren faktor bei den infizierten.
Weil ich selber auch auch bei italien weil ich mir nicht vorstellen kann,
dort die fallstelle zeit um so vieles höher sein sollte als in anderen ländern weil am ende hat man nämlich auch in china gesehen oder immer wenn das dann ausgelaufen.
Ist so lag die falsch sterblichkeit irgendwo bei drei vier prozent dann am ende und das,
wer halt bei italien ist es so so viel höher und bei großbritannien im moment auch das ist eigentlich verdächtig.
In der ganzen berichterstattung hat man natürlich extrem diese fokussierung auf nationen
und da stechen ja die usa gerade extrem heraus wenn man sozusagen wirklich diesen nation blick hat aber
man muss ja im prinzip mal und ein paar leute machen das online auch auch wenn ich nicht genau weiß auf welche zahlen die sich jetzt berufen habt ihr nur so ein paar kurven gesehen dass ich,
eu im vergleich zu den usa eigentlich ähnlich verhält.
Kann man sieht man ja auch schon überschlägig allein nur wenn man die zahlen jetzt von den großen ländern von italien spanien england deutschland frankreich zusammenzählt so dann.
Sind wir deutlich vor den usa europaweit.
Also vor nicht im es wird besser sondern vor im sinne von es ist schlimm.
Vor also mit vor meine ich dass die absoluten zahlen höher sind was aber auch vielleicht damit zu tun hat dass es hier früher losgegangen ist oder.
Ja das ist ja gar nicht mal unbedingt so ne also in den usa usa hatte ja auch glaube ich ihren ersten gemeldeten fall zeitgleich mit südkorea also im januar die haben dann nur sehr lange nicht darauf reagiert.
Und ich weiß gar nicht ob man so wenn man so den startpunkt hier setzen soll.
Also letztlich muss man alles irgendwie auf auf auf china angleichen im verlauf weil klar natürlich es sind viele leute von china auch nach italien geflogen sind natürlich auch viele in die usa geflogen et cetera und.
Irgendwo hat's mehr oder weniger dann doch zeitgleich angefangen.
Ja ja wobei das halt dann mir gesehen haben gerade am anfang bei der ausbreitung ist eine riesen rolle spielt.
Ob du irgendwelche super spreding ereignisse mit drin hast und wie viele und so und
wie sich das dann also wo sich das verteilt was von sicherlich sagen kann also new york hat's natürlich ziemlich krass gebeutelt aber wir sehen ja zum beispiel auch.
Jetzt an der verteilung der fälle in deutschland wo wir noch nicht viel darüber geredet haben aber im wesentlichen sind ja bayern.
Ja in nordrhein-westfalen gut die großen bundesländer allerdings gab es dort auch die größten hotspots und.
Ja baden-württemberg glaube ich im wesentlichen sind so die hauptattraktion und.
Was man ja jetzt sehen kann ist dass in anderen regionen dadurch dass jetzt der shutdown gekommen ist es ist jetzt nicht dort auch aufgeblüht ist
wie man wenn man jetzt keinen shutdown gemacht hätte während die anderen regionen einfach nachgezogen ja dann
während die ja sozusagen nur zeitlich versetzt aber dadurch dass es jetzt den shutdown gab.
Ist die mehr als begründete hoffnung da dass.
Das eben auch regionen gibt in deutschland die zwar nicht komplett verschont aber wo es halt ja viel früher jetzt zum stillstand gekommen ist und von demselben effekt könnte die usa.
Sagen auch profitieren wenn das nicht allzu gleichmäßig verteilt war sondern einige regionen erst dazu erst spät angefangen langsamer zu wachsen und ist sozusagen dort auch dann.
Gut vielleicht nicht in den die hatten jetzt auch kein landesweiten shutdown sondern es ging ja von bundesland zu bundesland auch unterschiedlich und teilweise haben sie es ja immer noch nicht.
Aber das das sozusagen das dass die usa da jetzt auch gerade glück.
Haben dass es eben nicht überall im land gleichmäßig aufblüht sondern jetzt jetzt auch es sind.
Weiten landesteilen so oder in der in der provinz dann,
doch nicht so schlimm kommt wie man das anfangs befürchten musste als man vor allen dingen die new yorker zahlen hatte die ja komplett die usa zahlen dominiert haben.
Doch immer noch tun.
Und interessant ist das aber zum beispiel auch in den usa an der westküste also los angeles und san francisco dass die halt.
Zwar auch ganz gut gebeutelt wurden aber nicht die dimension von new york erreicht haben das ist das das da.
Glimpflich abgelaufen ist.
Gut können wir vielleicht mal weg von den ganzen zahlen hin zu den maßnahmen die jetzt so langfristig angedacht werden.
Was was ja jetzt glaube ich ziemlich klar ist ist dass
alle romantischen vorstellungen von das geht dann auch schon wieder weg und dann dann wird wieder alles so wie vorher ich glaube das können wir irgendwie vergessen so also das ist,
problem mit dem wir uns jetzt nicht nur innerhalb eines news herumschlagen müssen sondern ein ziemlich großer wahrscheinlichkeit wird,
das ganze thema uns noch komplett mindestens dominieren.
Kann ich mir irgendwie nicht so richtig vorstellen dass es irgendwie anders läuft ja war man anfangs noch traurig über einen ausgefallenes,
fußballspiel oder ein spieltag und dann in der folge über so ein paar events,
denke ich mal muss man sich jetzt zumindest mal mit der situation an freunden das eigentlich so ziemlich alles stirbt in diesem jahr.
Also messen events alles mögliche urlaube et cetera und das natürlich auch die,
auswirkungen auf die wirtschaft noch lange sein werden und man muss sich halt in zunehmenden maße fragen,
okay wie können wir jetzt diese zeit bis denn dann das heilbringende impfstoff.
System in place ist kommt wie wie können wir wie können wir das sozusagen managen.
Wir drücken wir drücken die kurve aber wir wissen auch würden wir sofort wieder so weitermachen wie vorher sind noch genug leute die uninformiert sind
und es würde dann halt im prinzip wieder genauso losgehen wie vorher auch und wir hätten dasselbe problem was wir jetzt akut haben dauerhaft akut und dann vielleicht sogar noch viel schlimmer.
Ja es es hängt halt alles so ein bisschen davon ab wie wie viele.
Wie groß der der dunkel bereich ist aber ich würde es im moment nicht ganz so.
Pessimistisch sehen wie ich dich grade verstanden habe also erstmal.
Meine vermutung ist dass wahrscheinlich die
aktuellen maßnahmen noch bis zum ersten mai-wochenende also den wird man wahrscheinlich noch sagen mitnehmen wollen dass halt am montag den vierten mai
es meine vermutung wird man das allgemeine ausgeh-verbote lockern.
Ab dem vierten oder man wahrscheinlich hören werden falls es nicht schon verkündet wurde so dass das wahrscheinlich bis zum die maßnahmen bis zum dritten mai aufrecht erhalten werden wer.
In deutschland.
Ja
So genau und gut die die sache ist.
Das ja solche epidemien.
Übrigens breaking news ich habe gerade mal kurz die dich nachrichtenseiten gecheckt hauptmerk spiegel unterricht in schulen soll am vierten mai schrittweise wieder starten.
Okay ich hatte es wirklich noch nicht gelesen so sondern es war so ich hatte mir halt angeguckt oder nach dem jahr wahrscheinlich zwei wochen ist sozusagen minimum so noch also
und dann wird man wahrscheinlich den ja
hört mal irgendwie noch dass das erste mai wochenende den ersten mai wahrscheinlich noch versuchen ein bisschen
ja den daumen drauf zu halten so das.
Ja gut aber das problem ist ja in der welt und mögen wir das in deutschland auch früher hinbekommen bei anderen wird es später sein aber auch am vierten mai haben wir das problem ja noch also es.
Ja allerdings allerdings ich habe hoffnung auf grund von zwei dingen in dem moment.
Wo man die infektionsbad zahlen die die zahl der neuinfektionen runter hat auf sagen wir mal dreißig am tag dann
lassen sich wiederum die kontakte von den dreißig
lassen sich dann potenziell ermitteln und die dreißig und die ich sage mal dreitausend
leute mit denen die potenziell in kontakt waren alle unter quarantäne stellen und dann lässt sich das durch kontakt nach verfolgung wieder managen weil was man auch sagen muss.
Ist dass wir jetzt achtundneunzig prozent oder neunundneunzig prozent.
Neunundneunzig komma fünf prozent gesunde im moment in quarantäne haben.
Das ist natürlich ein grober klotz und nicht,
sehr effizient eigentlich würdest du gerne mal die null komma ein prozent unter quarantäne stellen und sagen abschirmen und nicht die neunundneunzig komma neun prozent die,
ungefährlich sind so im moment haben wir nur leider keine möglichkeit weil es so viele sind die einen von den anderen zu unterscheiden und deswegen
ja haben wir halt neunundneunzig komma neun prozent gesunde unter quarantäne so und,
in dem moment aber gesagt wenn wir runter sind unter dreißig oder so oder in.
So ein paar dutzend experten sagen wir könnten sogar ein paar hundert neue infektionen pro tag tracken.
Aber das ist nicht ganz einfach so und korea hats hingekriegt aber.
Singapur und taiwan die ja auch so beide als ein bisschen muster länder galten haben auch so ein bisschen die kontrolle verloren also haben jedenfalls auch dann.
Allerdings auf sehr niedrigem niveau sagen vierzehn tage halber shutdown oder so gemacht um das ganze wieder zu reduzieren und
korea wiederum hat das deswegen wahrscheinlich hingekriegt ich habe mir das angeschaut was haben die in korea gemacht.
Und die haben halt richtig bei beim kontakt nachverfolgen mit dem.
Ja groben maß zugeschlagen und haben dann eben auch mal zweihunderttausend leute unter quarantäne gestellt weil sie halt zu dieser sekte gehörten oder dreißigtausend die auf einer veranstaltung waren wo dann ein fall
bekannt geworden ist so damit müssten wir dann wahrscheinlich auch rechnen wenn wir dann sagen öffnen oder
wenn wir es dann unter kontrolle behalten müssen wir dann zumindest auf der die art und weise wahrscheinlich maßnahmen ergreifen indem wir.
Dann sagen okay wenn veranstaltungen stattfinden oder so und auf irgendeiner veranstaltung,
stellt sich raus war dann in infizierten werden dann halt alle veranstaltungsteam nehmer unter quarantäne gestellt ja
so und wenn du dann bei einem fußballspiel dabei bist mit hunderttausend leuten und da stellt sich raus da war dann ein infiziertes dabei dann hast du musst du halt hunderttausend leute in quarantäne schicken so.
Aber das ist immer noch besser als achtzig millionen sagen ja nicht unter quarantäne aber zumindest ja doch
deutlich in ihrer bewegungsfreiheit und in ihren möglichkeiten einzuschränken.
Ja aber das sind natürlich jetzt keine aussicht in anbetracht derer,
man gerne auch so eine veranstaltung geht was dann dazu führen wird dass halt viele leute auf diese veranstaltung gar nicht gehen was dann eben auch dazu führen wird dass viele veranstaltungen so auch erstmal gar nicht stattfinden also die auswirkungen sind jetzt nicht unbedingt also was ich nicht meinte ist
wir werden permanent bis zum ende des jahres im block down bleiben ich sagte nur.
Wir werden einschränkungen haben selbst wenn sie nicht verordnet sind das einfach viel von dem nicht stattfindet so bis hin zu
potenziellen dauer super sprayern wie was weiß ich stammkneipen und super enge partyveranstaltung und so weiter das ist natürlich nochmal so ein ganz anderer bereich aber das werden wir dann auch sehen
nichtsdestotrotz stellt sich natürlich genau jetzt hier die frage.
Wie kann man das eben begleiten und was ja schon ein bisschen länger in der diskussion ist wir hatten das ja auch glaube ich schon mal angerissen ist halt so diese idee mit wir haben doch alle smartphones in der tasche.
Könnt ihr uns das nicht vielleicht weiterhelfen.
Ja hatten wir ja beim letzten mal schon angeht.
Genau du warst ja auch überlegt ob du da mal ein bisschen mit bluetooth rumspielt bist du da überhaupt zugekommen,
wahrscheinlich nicht ne ja in der zwischenzeit gab's da interessante entwicklung weil ja apple und google jetzt auch an die öffentlichkeit gegangen sind und gesagt haben wir haben uns da mal was überlegt.
Und wir haben jetzt so eine technische maßnahme angekündigt indem sie quasi.
Ein system in ihre betriebssysteme integrieren oder in ihre smartphone in warmem einbringen wollen ihre fremdwort mit dem,
dieses contact tracing dieses bluetooth contact tracing vielleicht durchgeführt werden.
Könnte und das kann man die letzten freitag raus und ich fand das schon mal ganz interessant.
Dass sie sich da so zusammengeschlossen haben und dass sie im wesentlichen eigentlich auch auf dieselbe denselben schlüsse gekommen sind wie.
Das jetzt auch hier in der debatte ist.
Mein interessant ist wir hatten ja vor der vor der woche hatten wir
im prinzip auch gesagt ok es wird da sicherlich was in den oder im demnächst einen standard für geben für solches contact racing und dann dauert es nur offensichtlich nur zwei tage oder so.
Bist dann google und apple letztlich mit einem standard mit einem neuen vorgeprescht sind in die untereinander glaube ich wie ich das,
richtig verstanden.
Wo sie auch meinten wo sie jetzt schon seit zwei wochen also wo sie zu dem zeitpunkt wohl schon zwei wochen lang darüber beraten haben also.
Klar also es war so naheliegend dass dass es sich gar nicht lohnt sich dafür für die vorhersage groß auf die schulter zu klopfen nichtsdestotrotz ist es jetzt eben so gekommen und ich habe mir das mal angeschaut
und ja das ist wirklich ein sehr,
interessanter vorschlag wird's jetzt noch nicht so die zeit dir das anzugucken.
Nein deswegen ich hatte gehofft du würdest mir das jetzt erklären dass ich ja.
Was kann ich machen kann ich machen.
Ja dann schieß los.
Also die idee ist grundsätzlich diese man nutzt dieses bluetooth low energy.
System das ist glaube ich seit brutus vier null teil der spezifikation.
Und das ist im wesentlichen genau dafür geboren worden um eben dieses tracking.
Von telefonen oder das tracking von orten in der umgebung zu ermöglichen
das ist ja auch sagen wir mal eine legitime anwendung so der klassiker ist du hast so eine museums führung und du möchtest dann dir die exponate erklären lassen und es wäre ja ganz praktisch wenn dein telefon in der lage ist zu erkennen
ich stehe jetzt in der nähe von und dann
kann deine software entsprechend darauf reagieren und sagen so ah ja hier du stehst ja gerade vor diesem exponat hier ist die komplette erklärung dazu und dann läuft irgendein audio- los etcetera p
und diesen dienst den wollen sie nutzen und dazu haben sie einen sogenannten contact.
Action-serien definiert.
Bluetooth energy also man spricht auch von beacons und apple hat auch so diese bezeichnung natürlich mal,
geboren muss man sich halt so vorstellen wie so eine art bluetooth funk feuer also wie so ein kleiner leuchtturm der da steht aber er wirft halt nicht mit licht um sich so strahlt halt in bestimmten abständen ein ein kleines datenpaket.
Aus indem nicht sehr viel drin steht sondern im wesentlichen steht er einfach nur drin so hallo ich bin gerät x.
Und ich analysiere jetzt diesen dienst der in dem fall,
durch so einen sechzehn bit wert identifiziert wird das heißt da steht drin,
dieser dieses datenpaket ist der contraction service der ist sozusagen teil davon und dann wirft man halt noch zusätzlich eine mit.
Ist das so angedacht dass dieser diese sechzehn bit service ist das eine feste für den
service oder ist dran gedacht dass sozusagen unterschiedliche services mit unterschiedlichen dann noch unterwegs sind das ist was was ich denn den amerikanischen und den europäischen kontext detects service.
Ne das ist in dem fall wirklich nur dieser eine.
Okay sehr gut.
Generell wird hier einfach nicht in irgendeiner form mit nationen und so weiter unterschieden sondern es ist völlig egal du bist mit irgendwas im kontakt wo das auf dieser welt ist ist vollkommen,
egal und dieser dienst ist jetzt erstmal definiert worden damit du sozusagen diese datenpakete auseinander halten kannst also.
Wenn du halt jetzt wirklich im museum durch die gegend läuft und da ist halt irgendwie so ein blick und dann hat es einen anderen service so das heißt du kannst die pakete unterscheiden du siehst explizit so
das hier ist dieser dienst der genau für im kontext detects gedacht ist.
Und das ist so ein sechzehn bit werde ich weiß es nicht genau welcher aber halt einer,
so das heißt diese paket besteht im wesentlichen aus diesen drei komponenten die absender adresse des gerätes
die sogenannte make a dresse dann dieser service identify und dazu eben noch ein einhundertachtundzwanzig bitte
identify der sozusagen in dem moment eigentlich die quelle wirklich identifiziert
könnte man sagen naja das ist ja im gerät das gerät hat ja sowieso schon so ein absender warum man nimmt man nicht den naja das ist halt das gerät
da komme ich auch gleich nochmal dazu die ändert sich derzeit sowieso schon immer so es gibt auf jeden fall noch einen zusätzlichen hundertachtundzwanzig mit sogenannten rolling,
pro city identify also rolling der name sagt schon aus der ändert sich am laufenden meter.
Diese mekka adresse ist.
Ohnehin schon immer so ein problem gewesen weil man man braucht sowas ja eigentlich ne also wenn du so computer netzwerke hast man kennt das schon von internet da gab's so was du musst auf der aller niedrigsten ebene immer irgendwie sagen können wo kommt es her wo geht es hin sonst sonst kriegst du die pakete einfach nicht an diese richtigen
ordner und auf der einen seite willst du natürlich klar identifizieren wo kommt es her wo geht es hin auf der anderen seite ist das natürlich bei allem was ist
immer wieder dieses privacy problem dass du dadurch natürlich tracker bist wenn du die ganzen tag,
mit deinem gerät durch die weltgeschichte läufst und immer dieselbe idee hast dann sagst du im prinzip der welt die ganze zeit immer wo du bist und das will man natürlich verhindern deswegen ist irgendwann mal eingeführt worden dass ich diese zahl
sowieso immer ändert.
Könnte man sagen na ja okay dann reicht das ja vielleicht eigentlich auch aber die ist halt technisch gesehen nochmal was anderes trotzdem muss man das natürlich auch,
berücksichtigen weil eine identifizierung,
ist immer dann möglich wenn du irgendwas genau nachvollziehen kannst und wenn jetzt dieser rolling proximal identify diese hundertachtundzwanzig bitte
innerhalb dieses detects service wenn die sich jetzt zwar ändert und die soll sich so alle zehn bis zwanzig minuten also im schnitt alle fünfzehn minuten ändern.
Aber diese geräte adresse ändert sich in einem anderen zeitraum dann kannst du das ja immer.
Wieder zuordnen weil sich nur der eine teil ändert und der andere irgendwie nicht und hier zeigt sich eben auch warum
das sehr sinnvoll ist so ein dienst direkt in das betriebssystem einzubauen auf eine sehr sehr sehr niedrige ebene
weil dann nämlich sichergestellt werden kann dass wenn sich die eine ändert sich auch die andere damit du eben diese zuordnung nicht mehr machen kannst.
Das ist zum beispiel einer app
alleine so ohne weiteres gar nicht möglich weil sie diesen zugriff nicht hat weil sie das nicht forcieren kann oder zumindest nicht so ohne weiteres oder zumindest derzeit,
geht es halt nicht naja also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe soll also mit diesem contact detects service ein teilnehmendes gerät.
Ungefähr so viermal pro sekunde so ein so ein leuchtfeuer raussenden.
Also das heißt so zweihundert bis zweihundertsiebzig millisekunden das heißt so viermal pro sekunde sagte es hier.
Hier hier hier hier hier hier hier hier und das ist sozusagen jetzt erstmal die.
Erste basis man sendet raus und sagt ich bin jemand mit dem man.
Der gesehen werden kann ja aber meine ändert sich im schnitt alle fünfzehn minuten so dass ich eben nicht über einen längeren zeitraum eindeutig track überall bin.
So auf der anderen seite will man natürlich jetzt auch empfangen und das ganze protokoll basiert auf der idee.
Dass diese empfangen gesehenen leuchtfeuer auf dem telefon gespeichert werden und nur dort gespeichert werden und dort nur verbleiben.
Sie haben dann natürlich gleich gesagt so privacy ist total wichtig etcetera und dazu gehört halt erstmal das alles was du empfängst.
Verlässt das telefon nie.
Wenn du ein anderes ich sag jetzt mal funk feuer weil es das trifft es irgendwie ganz gut ne also wenn du so ein so ein ding empfängst.
Dann wird es abgespeichert mit seiner aber es wird auch noch zusätzlich abgespeichert mit dem zeitpunkt also ein times stamp.
Und mit der signalstärke dass so eine eigenschaft dieses bluetooth energy das.
In diesem paket auch noch enthalten ist mit welcher energie es los gesendet wurde und du kannst dann halt abspeichern auch.
Mit welcher energie du's empfangen hast und daraus kannst du dann eben rückschlüsse ziehen darauf wie weit es weg ist.
Wie gut das funktioniert wie klar dass eine aussage darüber macht wie weit etwas weg ist.
Hängt dann auch von ganz vielen anderen faktoren ab erstmal von der umgebung war da noch was dazwischen stand eine andere leute dazwischen war da eine scheibe dazwischen war da eine mauer dazwischen etcetera war da gar nichts dazwischen.
Wetter keine ahnung was da alles elektromagnetisch vielleicht noch eine rolle spielen kann trotzdem kriegst du halt schon mal so eine ahnung wie gut dieses signal ist oder wie wie wie nah dieses ding an dir zu sein.
Scheint und in diesem protokoll ist vorgesehen dass man so alle fünf minuten mal guckt ob man.
Was man denn so sieht und das dann einfach entsprechend einsammelt und abspeichert.
Also die app das die app sozusagen alle fünf minuten mal aufgeweckt wird und den kram weg schreibt oder macht das der service selber schon das betriebssystem.
Da bin ich mir nicht so ganz so sicher ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das betriebssystem das dann irgendwie zumindest schon mal einsammeln und die app muss es dann halt auch nochmal abholen oder wird dann entsprechend aufgeweckt.
Auch hier zeigt sich wieder dass diese betriebssystem integration eine ganz sinnvolle sache ist damit
das ganze nicht so viel akku frisst ne also wirst du nicht permanent alle fünf minuten geweckt sondern das wird dann eben automatisch kombiniert mit anderen make-ups die sowieso schon sind ne also wenn sowieso irgendeine andere app gerade in timer
kriegt oder irgendwas sowieso aufwacht oder du gerade dein telefon in die hand nimmst und es anlockt dass dass das dann eben in einem rahmen eines bestimmten,
zeitfenster optimiert wird dass man das dann halt einfach mitnimmt also sind nicht exakt genau fünf minuten so spätestens in etwa und so weiter.
So das heißt am ende landest du bei einem datenmaterial auf deinem telefon wo du einfach.
Im prinzip so zwei tabellen hast nämlich dieses eine ist halt welche.
Habe ich selber rausgesendet zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt und welche anderen habe ich gesehen und die liegen da jetzt erstmal rum.
Jetzt kommt halt der moment der wahrheit so irgendjemand hat dir gesagt du du bist aber jetzt mal total infiziert.
Du musst jetzt hier in behandlung quarantäne was auch immer so und das wäre doch mal ganz nett wenn du diese app jetzt benutzt hast dass du das diesem netzwerk auch sagen kannst.
Und in dem moment
gibst du quasi deine idee die du in einem bestimmten zeitraum der jetzt relevant ist also in der diskussion von kobi ist das halt.
Zwei wochen in etwa gibst du dann eben frei und sagst so hier unter diesen all dies war ich zu sehen.
Und das ganze wird dann eben über irgendeine server infrastruktur an alle anderen apps wieder verteilt das heißt diese.
Kontakt tracing app sammelt regelmäßig aus dem netzwerk diese veröffentlichten ein.
Und kann dann selber auf dem telefon nachschauen habe ich die gesehen ist die mit mir in kontakt getreten.
Konkret läuft das nicht so dass jetzt alle diese rausgegeben werden sondern da ist natürlich auch noch ein bisschen kryptographie am start.
Und zwar aus so ganz praktischen erwägungen also wenn man jetzt alle fünfzehn minuten seine idee ändert.
Dann bedeutet das dass du halt innerhalb von vierundzwanzig stunden entsprechend die vierfache menge an all dies hättest ne.
Also sechsundneunzig all dies und da die halt dann acht beides haben oder achtundzwanzig.
Bit werden das dann irgendwie schon mal siebenhundertachtundsechzig beides so rein netto daten und das ganze mal vierzehn tage werden irgendwie schon mal so satte zehn kilo beide ungefähr.
Das kann eine ganze menge werden irgendwann weil wenn du wirklich davon ausgehst dass da tausende oder hunderttausende solche veröffentlicht werden im schlimmsten fall so dann
sammelt sich das eben an über die tage von daher hat man von vornherein auch.
Drüber nachgedacht hier die daten zu reduzieren und deswegen gibst du nicht alle all dies frei.
Sondern diese all dies werden tatsächlich kryptografisch aus einem schlüssel generiert der sich jeden tag ändert.
Das heißt du hast quasi so ein masterkey aus dem sich dann für jeden tag ein neuer kiel ableitet und aus diesem täglichen kiel leiten sich die ganzen all dies ab.
So dass du nur diesen daily veröffentlichen musst für diese tage die relevant sind und dann können sich die anderen telefone einfach kryptografisch aus diesem delikt die ganzen anderen auch ableiten
das heißt die,
müssen nicht die komplette liste empfangen sondern die kriegen quasi nur so eine zahl pro tag und können sich dann alle anderen all dies daraus ableiten nehmen sich dann eben diese liste und gucken dann in ihrer eigenen tabelle nach habe ich irgendwas gesehen.
Und habe ich was gesehen ist natürlich jetzt.
Nicht so eine reine ja nein sache sondern dann muss halt in irgendeiner form und da sagt halt das protokoll jetzt erstmal überhaupt nichts drüber aus wie das ablaufen soll ja du musst ja dann gewichten.
Habe ich den nur einmal kurz gesehen den zweimal gesehen habe ich den vielleicht auch über einen zeitraum von fünfzehn minuten gesehen länger als fünfzehn minuten gesehen.
Wie stark war das signal in dem moment ja also man kann da ja alles mögliche reininterpretieren ja ist das irgendwie so ein typisches signal was weiß ich habe.
Einmal was gesehen und dann nochmal aber es war beides mal ganz schwach aus der ferne et cetera also diese relevanz kriterien um rauszusuchen hat hier einen kontakt tatsächlich stattgefunden.
Es gibt jetzt erstmal dieses protokoll so gar nicht raus das protokoll was die definiert sagt im prinzip nur so wird es generiert so wird es in der luft verteilt,
so soll es eingesammelt werden und so soll es gespeichert werden und das sind hier die aktiven bestandteile an informationen da drin.
Aber wie man diese information letzten endes in relation setzt sagt es so erstmal nicht aus das heißt das ist auch das ist ja auch etwas was ich über die zeit ändern kann.
Macht sinn ja.
Neue erkenntnisse sind so dinge wo das protokoll erstmal überhaupt gar keine annahmen macht sondern sagt einfach nur so wie wir wissen ihr wollt irgendwie tracing machen wie ihr das dann am ende ausrechnet ist eure geschichte
wir nehmen euch aber den teil ab der auch schnell falsch gemacht werden kann wo die crypto falsch gemacht werden kann
wo die kommunikation falsch gemacht werden kann wo ihr das telefon die batterie leer saugt wenn ihr was falsch macht et cetera
wo das ganze im hintergrund laufen kann ohne dass eure ab irgendwas tun muss also sie neben einem sozusagen so einen kritischen teil weg und stellen damit.
Quasi so eine infrastruktur bereit in die man sich dann so reinklemmen kann.
Teil der spezifikation ist dann auch noch eine eine art also eine definition wie programm es darauf zugreifen und die ist dann halt auf.
Android und auf ios in der sache das dasselbe ding ne also,
in abhängigkeit von deinen programmiersprachen und umgebung und so weiter und bei android mit java und auf eiweiß dann halt mit objective klar sieht das dann konkret geschrieben anders aus aber die logik ist dieselbe und die daten sind die selbe und die krypto ist dieselbe.
Und von daher ist das schon so ein modell was in meinen augen schon mal ganz klug.
Entworfen worden ist und sicherlich dazu führen wird dass,
zumindest einige länder die entweder noch nicht so weit waren überhaupt darüber nachzudenken
oder die vielleicht mit anderen sachen schon so in einem ähnlichen bereich gefischt haben aber sich noch nicht so ganz sicher waren worauf sie sich jetzt eigentlich einlassen sollen
dass dass das schon so ein angebot ist von dem ich sagen würde hat eine relativ hohe wahrscheinlichkeit dass das konzept dann auch angenommen wird zumal es einfach.
Innerhalb kürzester zeit wir reden jetzt von mai irgendwann haben sie gesagt können sie es rauswerfen.
Über system updates auf relativ große zahl von geräten eingespielt werden kann.
Ja dann natürlich dann wieder apple wahrscheinlich den vorteil gegenüber der android welt so weil natürlich dann die hersteller auch mitziehen,
müssen und updates rausgeben müssen während apple das natürlich alles selber in der hand hat und das ist ja auch das
iphone user deutlich aktuellere systeme fahren als android user weil einfach das angebot besser ist.
Ja ist richtig aber sie können das über ihr sie haben ja schon vor einiger zeit auf andere angefangen diese ganzen updates feature updates nicht ausschließlich über das us zu machen sondern über dieses google play.
An dem ja nicht alle andere die weißes teilnehmen aber alles was sozusagen die google infrastruktur hat kann glaube ich google bis zu andere im prinzip
so ein angebot machen.
Und die telefone die das nutzen die können dann zumindest richtig sehr store base auch von so achtzig fünfundachtzig prozent erreichen.
Ich bin gespannt was mit huawei handys.
Ja ja klar bei den chinesen sieht das natürlich dann ganz anders aus wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe wollen sie aber
quasi diesen protokoll teil auch open source veröffentlichen also sie werden halt code veröffentlichen mit dem man das im prinzip dann auch implementieren kann beziehungsweise ich nehme auch mal an google wird es dann
quasi auch ins android selber in irgendeiner form einbauen oder ein baubach machen sodass theoretisch.
Andere us-herstellers die sich nur auf android als basis beziehen aber dann ihren eigenen kram drauf machen in der lage wären das dann halt dort auch einzubauen und an ihre bedürfnisse anzupassen aber das wird natürlich dann entsprechend länger dauern,
und ob es passieren wird kann ja auch nicht sagen ja.
Ok
Ich hab's verstanden wie es funktioniert danke für die erklärung so ja und,
muss man sagen erstmal auf den ersten blick sieht das ganze doch recht solide.
Aus also zumindest überlege ich jetzt gerade okay was sind denn jetzt hier mögliche,
angriffs szenarien eigentlich und.
Ja gut grundsätzlich kann,
natürlich ist es immer die eine kritische sache wann sendet jemand eigentlich so eine warnung raus oder wie wird.
Verhindert oder muss man eigentlich verhindern dass solche warnungen rausgesendet werden was jetzt das datensammeln selber angeht.
Ja
Kann ich mir theoretisch auch den einen oder anderen angriff vorstellen den ich aber halte ich aber nicht für praktikabel also,
kann es natürlich wenn du anfängst irgendwie bieten zu sammeln an irgendeiner
stelle und veranstaltungen und das dann mit anderen daten eventuell korrigierst von den geräten so dann ja.
Ja das ist so das ist so diese angst mit können können jetzt irgendwelche kommerziellen tracker da irgendwas draus gewinnen das ist
also aus meiner warte herden in ihren theoretisches problem zunächst ist es ja mal so
keine dieser information gehen irgendwie raus nur wenn jemand sozusagen als infiziert gemeldet ist wenn wenn solche kies veröffentlicht dann wird sozusagen
ein blick in dieses wer mit wem theoretisch aber halt auch nur die eine seite geblickt ne wenn jetzt so eine kaskade hast mit,
einer veröffentlicht und alle die mit dem in kontakt waren veröffentlichen auch und veröffentlichen auch klar daraus lässt sich dann sozusagen tatsächlich so ein scheiß baum theoretisch herstellen die frage ist nur wer hat davon einen großen nutzen
erstmal ist es immer noch alles anonym
ja also du kannst sozusagen aus den daten selber keinerlei identifikation machen da steckt nichts dran das sind einfach nur zahlen du müsstest könntest es nur tun wenn du eben selber.
Jetzt herrscher über die entsprechende nationale infrastruktur bist nur dann ist es halt so leute die getestet werden.
Die werden sowieso aufgeschrieben und diese informationen und dann hast du sozusagen den kompletten gesundheitsversorgung an der stelle mit anschrift und,
und pipapo da ist jetzt das was in diesen daten drinsteckt.
Absolut sekundär und das jetzt leute anfangen draußen irgendwelche bluetooth empfänger aufzuhängen in der hoffnung diese diese zahlen einzusammeln und daraus.
Irgendwas abzuleiten sehe ich halt auch irgendwie auch nicht weil,
dafür ist das protokoll dann doch eben durch seine permanent ändernden anonym genug als dass du dir da irgendeinen räumten rein drauf machen kannst das einzige was du sehen kannst ist hier laufen leute vorbei die das tatsächlich eingeschaltet haben.
Das war's dann aber eigentlich im wesentlichen auch.
Na ja du kannst natürlich in dann bestimmten sondersituationen wenn du weißt zum beispiel da ist hält sich jetzt gerade nur eine person auf
in dem bereich kannst du natürlich unter umständen sagen für eine.
Person dann in einem bereich was einsammeln oder aber ich gebe dir.
Recht also ich sehe jetzt nicht die möglichkeit erstmal ohne weiteres das in einem großen stil.
Irgendwo angriffe zu fahren an der stelle wobei ich da jetzt auch noch nicht lange drüber nachgedacht habe muss ich sagen.
Es gibt probleme aber nicht das
so ja also gerade dieses wenn da nur eine person ist und ich weiß wer die ist ne dann weißt du sowieso schon wo diese person ist und wer das ist also da gibt es dann keinen großen gewinn so das ist einfach mir fällt es einfach schwer daraus große bedrohliche szenarien abzuleiten,
aber grundsätzlich hat natürlich gibt es schon noch probleme und das fängt natürlich erst mal damit an.
Wer darf jetzt überhaupt in diese server infrastruktur eine meldung.
Ablegen war natürlich dass das hauptproblem was ich hier wirklich sehe ist natürlich du du schaffst eine architektur wo leute gewarnt werden.
Wo leute handlungen draus ableiten für sich,
sich in quarantäne bringen sich testen lassen sie werden in irgendeiner form aus ihrem lebensrythmus rausgeworfen das erzeugt angst etcetera vorbehalte alles mögliche das heißt dieses diese angst vor ich werde
gewarnt ist an sich ja schon da einfach angst überhaupt ne deswegen werden vielleicht die leute auch gar nicht dran teilnehmen weil sie sich denken so
virus ich will das thema überhaupt gar nicht haben auch schon gar nicht auf meinem telefon und dann sagt mir das irgendwie auch noch bescheid sagen ich wie ich was weiß ich ich will dann einfach nur sterben oder ich werde schon irgendwie überleben und vielleicht.
Gar nicht und so weiter also diese ängste bestehen natürlich und das ist sozusagen das vertrauen was man dem system auch erstmal entgegenbringen muss um überhaupt daran teilzunehmen
was ich vorher nicht gesagt habe ist das protokoll sieht explizit vor dass man sich hier auch nur lesen.
Dran beteiligt also es wird sozusagen so ein switch geben mit ich ich nehme an diesem system teil und einen zweiten switch der sagt.
Ich nehme auch schreiben also senden an diesem system teil also du kannst sozusagen.
Alle einsammeln die du siehst ohne selber zu sagen dass du da warst also sogar das gibt es macht
aus meinen augen nicht so richtig viel sinn aber es zumindest möglich aber das hauptproblem ist
erstmal diese frage wie verhinderst du einfach diese tollerei weil wir wissen es gibt genug leute die dann einfach sagen würde jetzt schicke ich hier massenhaft irgendwelche meldungen raus macht die leute verrückt,
oder schickt die bewusst in die quarantäne oder so ich schraube jetzt hier einen bluetooths handy an den hund und der läuft jetzt mal durch die gegend und hat somit allen irgendwie kontakt und dann meldet sich der hund krank.
Klar also muss man natürlich verhindern und das bedeutet du musst schon mal diese.
Problematik lösen wie gibst du überhaupt also unter welchen bedingungen darf überhaupt jemand sagen ich bin infiziert.
Das heißt du musst hier erstmal eine absicherung haben was sie auch vergessen hatte zu erwähnen zugriff auf diese app und die zugriff auf diese rechte an diesem datenpool an diesem protokoll überhaupt teilzuhaben werden.
In den appstores halt nur an offizielle apps verteilt das ist jetzt nicht etwas wo jetzt jeder hinz und kunst irgendwie meine corona tracing app.
Veröffentlichen kann sondern es wird nur eine handvoll geben und das wird in irgendeiner form eben wie sie sagen mit den gesundheitsbehörden des jeweiligen landes ausgekaspert werden das heißt es wird in deutschland.
Maximal eine app geben so.
Trotzdem muss die natürlich dieses problem lösen und das kann halt eigentlich nur darüber gehen dass wenn man in irgendeiner form ein sicheren prozess macht.
Ich glaube diese pepp leute hatten so eine tan vorgeschlagen also dass man so quasi.
So freischalte all dies an entsprechende test organisation oder ärzte ausgibt sodass die dir dann an die leute weiterreichen können und nur mit dieser tat dieser transaktionsnummer kannst du dann sozusagen so eine meldung machen,
was ich auch problematisch weil die können dann abhanden kommen können geklaut werden können gehackt werden können weit verteilt werden etcetera also das
muss man schon nochmal drüber nachdenken was da der richtige weg wäre ich denke ja irgendwie so was wie so ein so eine regionale geschichte also
du musst halt da explizit dich freischalten lassen dass du da jetzt diese daten über übersenden kannst und dann landen die halt erst im system.
Das habe ich auf jeden fall ein problem was noch gelöst werden muss
es gab jetzt schon so eine stellungnahme hier von der pfiff zu privacy datenschutz fragen rund um solche apps die ihr also auch von diesem ähnlichen modell ausgehen also die sich jetzt nicht explizit auf apple und google bezogen haben sondern
wesentlichen auf den vorschlag sowie dinos in.
Veröffentlicht hat minus macht ja logbuch netzpolitik zusammen und der hat da auch ein entsprechendes statement gemacht und schon mal so dieses modell im prinzip auch schon mal beschrieben.
Und das haben wir auch bei logbuch netzpolitik ausführlich diskutiert und das entspricht ja im wesentlichen dem wie auch apple und google das jetzt umgesetzt haben also da sind die ideen sind eigentlich dieselben und.
Was auf jeden fall ein punkt ist ist man muss natürlich auch davon ausgehen dass jemand auch falsch positiv bewertet wird.
Also nur weil du jetzt einen test hattest der sagt du bist positiv.
Heißt das ja nicht unbedingt dass das auch immer so bleiben muss diese feststellung das kann sehr gut sein dass du dann nochmal einen zweiten test machst und dann.
Ist unter umständen diese information schon raus also man muss sich auch darüber gedanken machen wie man so eine attraktion machen kann dass man sozusagen sowas auch wieder zurücknimmt dass sowas auch dann entsprechend im user interface auch angezeigt wird nach dem motto war nur ein fehlalarm.
So eine geschichten.
Ja dann gibt's natürlich viel diskussionen darum so was macht das so mit uns ne also ist so eine app infrastruktur in der lage hier so auf so einem compliance verhalten hinzuwirken also.
Es gibt ja so szenarien dass leute sagen ja wenn so eine app gibt und alle müssen dran teilnehmen da wird man dann dazu gezwungen und wenn du nicht richtig dazu gezwungen werden kannst
dann dann wirst du sozial dazu gezwungen weil wenn es irgendwie nicht zeigen kannst dass sie auf deine app dich grün anzeigt sozusagen dann darfst du nicht rein in den club
das ist natürlich quatsch eigentlich also es ist technisch finde ich eigentlich gar kein.
Problem weil die app kanal überhaupt nichts beweisen die app kann ich beweisen dass du.
Gesund bist ja soll also wenn du das zeigst beweist es halt erstmal gar nichts.
Das heißt nur im besten fall auf deiner app ist noch nicht so eine warnmeldung angekommen.
Und wenn du wenn du sozusagen dahingehend bedenken hättest dass du sowas nicht mehr zeigen kannst naja dann geht der trend halt zum zweit handy so oder liegst dein handy im schrank und holst es irgendwie immer raus.
Ja also niemand kann kann irgendwie so ein telefon du kannst nicht kann sich sicherstellen dass ein telefon in irgendeiner form zuverlässig anzeigt
dass diese person in kontakt mit jemandem war der als infiziert gilt
also es ist eigentlich nicht machbar ich kann mir vorstellen dass leute sich solche gedanken machen aber ich
see das ehrlich gesagt in diesem technischen szenario nicht als als möglichkeit an.
Ja ich jetzt gerade auch nochmal überlegt was denn so
sagen was denn so missbrauchs möglichkeiten wäre oder wie schlimm dieser missbrauch denn dann tatsächlich ist oder gehen wir mal erst mal davon aus was denn der bestimmungsgemäßer gebrauch denn
so wäre in der praxis und gehen wir mal davon aus dass.
Bis die app da ist irgendwann sich zumindest bei uns hoffentlich die zahlen auch soweit reduziert hat dass wir irgendwo unter,
hundert sind so dann reden wir von dreißig bis fünfzig.
Festgestellten oder nehmen wir mal hundert festgestellten neuinfektionen pro tag oder lass es auch tausend sein ja dann.
Sind das sagen tausend meldungen am tag im normalfall oder zwischen fünfzig und tausend meldungen so.
In deutschland die dann in so einem system reingehen wenn du jetzt.
Bei hundert fällen tausend meldungen wie meinst du das jetzt.
Bei bei einhundert bis eintausend neuinfektionen am tag.
Okay also tausend.
Zu sagen dass irgendwo in der gegend wird sich dann normalerweise bewegen.
Also nicht wirklich viel erstmal so jetzt.
Hat wahrscheinlich dann jeder aus den vierzehn tagen gut interessant zu sehen wie viel.
Verschiedene man denn so eigentlich ein sammelt bei einem normalen.
Tag wenn man unterwegs ist,
aber dann kommt es natürlich noch drauf drauf an nicht jede die man jetzt unbedingt empfängt erfüllt dann das kriterium
tatsächlich für einen für einen schwellenwert oder so sondern wir hatten ja also bei anderen,
varianten gesagt man muss sagen wenigstens zwanzig minuten oder so oder eine.
Oder zumindest mehrere minuten.
Mit jemandem verbracht haben und wenn die jetzt die beacons irgendwie fünfmal pro sekunde.
Senden ja dann muss man eine ganze menge davon empfangen erstmal um.
Na du guckst halt alle fünf minuten nach was ist denn so um mich herum so das heißt du hast für so 'n so 'n zeit bereich von fünfzehn bis zwanzig minuten hast du halt so ein paar samples und du kannst halt später wenn du diesen diese kies empfängst
selbst wenn die die sich in dem moment geändert hat von deinem gegenüber kannst du sehen ah okay da hat sie sich geändert du weißt du auch wenn sie sich geändert hat ist immer dieselbe person,
du kannst schon mal alles einschränken
was irgendwie mindestens fünfzehn minuten jetzt mal gehen wir mal von dieser zahl aus ja also noch mal fünfzehn minuten ist so der schwellenwert sprich du müsstest halt in in fünf minuten abständen um dich herum schauen und in drei
aufeinander folgenden suchen dieselbe oder,
eine aldi derselben gerätes auch wenn sich geändert hat empfang und sie müsste in allen drei fällen auch eine gewisse signalstärke haben die sagt,
stand in deiner nähe so was weiß ich wenn wir hier im podcast studio zusammensitzen podcast aufnehmen und so weiter wäre das zum beispiel der fall.
Das wäre dann sozusagen das event was es zu berichten gilt.
Das heißt mit einer jetzt ungeschickte
app also mit einer so einer app im originalzustand ist der einzige missbrauch den du jetzt machen kannst ist rumzulaufen möglichst viele solcher kontakte,
einzusammeln was aber wie gesagt gar nicht so einfach ist wenn
die app selber erst wenn du fünfzehn minuten an irgendeinem platz bleiben muss das heißt das beste das heißt nützt ja auch nicht sich an irgendwie eine viel befahrene straße zu setzen oder in den kaffee zu setzen weil die leute die da einfach nur hin und her vorbeilaufen.
Werden halt auch nicht registriert das heißt du musst schon irgendwo von einer größeren menschen ansammlung zu einer anderen menschen ansammlung gehen und die
jeweils eine ganze weile aufhalten wo sich halt auch andere leute aufhalten damit du
signifikant viele einsammelt wenn du jetzt den missbrauch planst und dann würdest du irgendwann
das kannst du jetzt vierzehn tage lang machen und dann kannst du sagen vierzehn tage lang all die leute belästigen die
du da eingesammelt hast weil ein punkt ist diese sind halt zufällige hundertachtundzwanzig bezahlen die kann man nicht erraten.
Kannst du nicht wenn du jetzt hingehen würdest dass wir jetzt das nächste ding und du du guckst jetzt die app kannst du also auch schon mal.
Nicht ohne weiteres die die erraten so sondern das müssen sie müssten dann schon von echten beacons stammen und,
die andere sache ist das ja maximal vierzehn tage zeit hast jetzt so einen dicken missbrauchs datenschatz
anzulegen was man sich jetzt vorstellen könnte wäre das irgendwie eine organisation von bösen hackern sich zusammentut und ein netzwerk bildet
und dann dort ganz viele,
ladies aggregiert von ganz vielen leuten die rumlaufen und dann darüber sagen dann mit einer gehackten app,
diese ganz ganz vielen dank an den surver schick.
Nee du schickst ja nicht deren all dies an den server du schickst ja nur deine eigenen.
Ah
Das ist ja das ding also du einsammeln hilft dir überhaupt nichts ja sondern.
Ok stimmt ja ja.
Du du du bist der.
Du bist der fall und nur du sagst ich war draußen und wer und und die anderen schauen nur so a da behauptet jemand könnte vielleicht in deiner nähe gewesen sein schauen wir doch mal nach
weil du ja deine eigenen daten zu dem zeitpunkt noch gar nicht rausgegeben hast und du guckst halt einfach nur habe ich den der da jetzt gerade veröffentlicht wurde schon mal gesehen.
Ja ja okay selbst dann okay okay dann ja ist das szenario nicht wirklich.
Du kannst jetzt leute die ganze zeit hinterher rennen aber dann müsstest du am ende ja immer noch durch diesen prozess desinfiziert werdens durchgehen also es ist einfach quatsch.
Okay dann dann dann würde ja dann dann würde es sozusagen nur so umgehen dass sagen ganz viele leute irgendwie.
Mit.
Entsprechend gehackten apps rumlaufen sich ihre daten dort auslesen und alle gemeinsam ihre daten dann poolen und dass dann einer von denen dann
sagen sagt okay und ich war jetzt hier infiziert aber das klingt das.
Einfach.
Jetzt nicht so richtig nach einem nach einem.
Angriff.
Irgendwie wirklich praktikablen angriff so und wie gesagt ausdenken.
Kann man sich die dinger nicht da wird's dann keine matches geben du kannst natürlich,
ja versuchen so ein die service angriff auf den server zu fahren indem du versuchst den dann mit daten zu fluten aber ich würde mal vermuten,
das auch relativ klar ist dass von einem gerät neue begrenzte zahl an daten kommen können sei es selbst.
Das ist auf server seite dann relativ einfach zu verhindern dass dass das passiert und.
Und du kannst diese ganze submission halt auch nochmal kryptografisch absichern also das sozusagen wirklich diese meldung muss dann explizit signiert sein von einem testen den institut,
so die eine spezielle variante dieser app haben mit der,
das andere telefon also muss sagen ok ich will jetzt melden und dann wird das mit zum anderen telefon kurz verbunden und das sagt ja okay alles klar du darfst jetzt eine meldung machen
mit deinen kies die darfst du jetzt rausschicken aber du musst die halt vorher noch von mir signieren lassen und dann steht da drin hier sowieso institut.
Test offiziell abgesegnet doppelt unterschrieben vom so und nur das wird dann überhaupt
angenommen und rausgemacht es kann natürlich softwaretechnisch irgendwo immer was schiefgeht aber vom system her.
Fällt es mir schwer.
Es ist so oder so schon schon schon schwierig da was zu iniziieren und selbst wenn es einem gelingt könnte es.
Fast keine auswirkungen haben weil wie du schon gesagt hast man kann halt diese anderen all dies nicht erraten also dass die müssen dich dann halt auch
gesehen haben und da frage ich mich halt auch wirklich wer will jetzt so ein aufwand betreiben willst du dann irgendwie mit mit irgendwie dreißig leuten durch die fußgängerzone irgendwie leuten hinterherrennen und immer schön in der warteschlange hinter ihnen stehen ich meine bisher auch bekloppt wenn du dich in diese gefahr begibst ist.
Warum sollte man denn das jetzt auch noch tun also wo wo wo ist da der gewinn also was was was was kann man davon haben fällt mir einfach schwer.
Entsprechende sachen raus machen es gibt er halt war bei den datenschützern auch so einen punkt ne.
Ok was er da so für rechtliche auswirkung et cetera wenn man jetzt leuten empfiehlt.
Hier dein telefon hat jemanden gesehen und man kriegt ja.
Auch nur diese information dadurch dass das ganze so privacy mäßig ist.
Und da leute sich wahrscheinlich auch dagegen wehren würden wenn diese app sagt hallo ich möchte ganz gerne auch noch meine deine location noch treffen wo sie dann gleich so panik oh gott wer aber eigentlich ganz sinnvoll
wenn ich meine eigenen bitcoins speichere dass ich in dem moment auch weiß wo ich da war also ich ich würde das
für mich gerne haben ich verstehe natürlich dass das nicht teil des protokolle ist weil dann alle zurecht auch aufschreien würden und das
potentiellen missbrauch auch noch nach sich ziehen können aber so als convenience wäre es für mich eigentlich ganz gut trotzdem bekomme ich die information,
wann dieser kontakt war weil der times stamp ist ja drin das heißt die app kann mir das sagen und es reicht dann wahrscheinlich auch für mich schon sprich ich werde jetzt.
Zieh meine app raus die app verbindet sich mit dem netz die lädt sich die neuesten gemeldeten,
infektionsweg runter wo drin steht hier diese person ist als offiziell als infiziert gemeldet
haben wir auch überprüft stimmt so dann kommt die app sagt okay alles klar neue kies gucken wir nochmal nach rechnet sich die all dies aus die ist da hätte sehen müssen und stellt fest
oha hier mit der einen habe ich dann tatsächlich mal eine stunde zusammen irgendwo rumgesessen am um
sei es soweit datum und uhrzeit und kannst wahrscheinlich relativ gut dann auch nachvollziehen wann und wo das war,
also wann es war sowieso aber dann weiß wahrscheinlich auch wo war im büro war im supermarkt war im zug war im auto keine ahnung so und dann kannst du deine schlüsse daraus ziehen.
Dann kriegst du quasi den hinweis du warst mit jemandem zusammen der jetzt als infektiös bekannt ist,
und der vermutlich in diesem zeitraum unter umständen mit einer bestimmten wahrscheinlichkeit auch schon,
infektion war so und dann ist die frage was bedeutet das für dich musst du dich jetzt melden.
Musst du dich sofort in quarantäne zurückziehen was ist wenn du das nicht machst,
hat das rechtliche folgen für dich ja ist es dann sozusagen körperverletzung oder was auch immer wenn du dann nicht irgendwelche maßnahmen wie müssen die belegt wird also das sind solche fragen die sich daraus sicherlich noch ableiten werden und die es zu klären gilt,
aber ich glaube halt nach wie vor dass das ich will nicht sagen es ist wasserdicht dafür bin ich dann.
Auch nicht experte genug so aber ich sage mir mir persönlich macht das eigentlich überhaupt gar keine sorgen die frage ist natürlich jetzt auch lohnt sich der aufwand.
Bringt uns das was.
Vielleicht kurz nochmal zu zu dem problem was so gerade geschildert hast das sehe ich gar nicht so,
kritisch weil wir ja es handelt sich ja um eine meldepflichtig erkrankung.
So das heißt die gesundheitsämtern also wenn du den,
wenn ein arzt das jetzt diagnostiziert oder der verdacht besteht so bei jemandem dann also derjenige der getestet wurde jetzt.
Der ist ja beim gesundheitsamt gemeldet so und.
Der muss ja dann ohnehin einmal seine kontakte von denen der weiß dann dort angeben im rahmen dieses prozesses heute,
und die werden dann vom gesundheitsamt benachrichtigt das ist ja der der existierende
prozess im moment und jeder kontakt da den musst du selber bisher klassifizieren als nach wie
lange und nach bestimmten kriterien und und so
beziehungsweise deinen kontakt mit mit der mit der entsprechenden person so und dann wird es in unterschiedliche risiko kategorien je nachdem in welcher risiko kategorie wie lange und wie nah und so
kriegst du dann eine aufforderung in quarantäne
zu gehen so das heißt rechtlich ist es sozusagen gibt es im moment irgendwie da einen einen prozess der ganz unabhängig von app oder
allem funktioniert so wenn du jetzt so eine benachrichtigung kriegst.
Ist es natürlich immer noch an dir erstmal zu beurteilen und einzuschätzen okay
aber zu dem zeitpunkt war ich irgendwie keine ahnung alleine in meinem zimmer oder ich war alleine mit dem auto unterwegs das heißt was auch immer da irgendwie an kontakt war
okay da habe ich vielleicht neben jemandem im stau gestanden durch.
Oder oder es hat hier hat jemand seit seinem telefon in meinem auto vergessen.
Genau
irgendwie irgendwie sowas so das heißt es ob liegt dann eigentlich dir dann festzustellen dass das ganze zu bewerten und das kann auch
sonst eigentlich kein anderer machen und dann kannst du dich halt je nachdem selber entscheiden wenn das du dich ans gesundheitsamt oder nicht so und
dann haben die allerdings auch nicht ohne weiteres eine möglichkeit des des jetzt zuzuordnen es sei denn.
Der infizierte hat dann irgendwie eine liste von kontakten.
Aufgestellt aber dann würdest du ohnehin benachrichtigt werden so das heißt am ende
kann das eigentlich nur ein indikator dafür sein dass du dich meldest und dich untersuchen.
Lässt oder dich erstmal also es liegt dann dir ob du dich dann erstmal in selbst begibst ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass so eine meldung jetzt alleine nur
irgendwie kontakt hat bestanden dass daraus irgendwelche rechtlichen verpflichtungen
erwachsen können aber also es wäre glaube ich auch eher kontraproduktiv wenn das der fall wäre weil da würden die leute sagen
also bevor ich mich diesem risiko jetzt aussetze da dann lasse ich das doch lieber mit der mit der app.
Genau das ist vor allem sehr einfach sowas auszuschalten du schaltest da irgendwie dein bluetooth aus dann nimmst du schon mal nicht dran teil so also man kann das sehr schnell ausschalten für sich man man löscht die app man schaltet die funktion aus man benutzt ein,
überhaupt nicht mehr es ist sehr einfach irgendwas nicht zu benutzen man kann auch nicht dafür verurteilt werden dass das eigene telefon kaputt war und man kein geld hat sich ein neues zu kaufen die teilnahme ist halt einfach freiwillig aber wo es halt wirklich
helfen könnte und dann geht natürlich die.
Einschätzung davon wie erfolgreich sowas sein kann sehr weit auseinander ist eben diesen prozess mit ein infiziertes ist gefunden worden und wir wollen noch,
möglichst während die andere leute die in kontakt waren die dieses virus jetzt von dieser person erhalten haben wollen wir noch in deren infektionen zeit.
Also in der sie selber infizieren sind also ansteckend sind.
Dafür sorgen dass diese person sich so schnell wie möglich rausnehmen weil das ist ja das drama dieses saß kopf zwei virus man ist einfach schon mal fünf sechs tage lang.
Ansteckend bevor man selbst auch nur die chance hat zu merken dass man das hat am körperlichen verhalten und manchmal merkt man noch nicht mal das.
Das heißt eigentlich was man eigentlich machen muss ich hatte das nämlich auch mal als wäre er vorhin von der generationen zeit von vier tagen gesprochen.
Im schnitt werden die leute kriegen erst symptome am fünften tag und lassen sich dann wahrscheinlich am sechsten oder siebten tag erst testen.
So dann kommt am achten oder neunten tag das testergebnis das heißt du kannst jetzt sagen dass.
Ich sage mal die leute vielleicht am neunten zehnten oder tag sozusagen am zehnten tag ist so so glaube ich zehn komma fünf tage.
Unglaublich hatte ich den durchschnitt plus minus war zwischendurch mal ein bisschen länger aber so also zehn tage,
liegt jetzt das infektionserkrankung bis zurück und du bist eventuell jetzt zwar noch infektiös aber bist halt eigentlich sieben tage zurück wirkend
kannst du jetzt jemanden angesteckt haben das heißt,
mittlerweile aber den sieben tagen bis zu fast schon in der in der zweiten generation drin das heißt.
Eigentlich wäre es dann wiederum sinnvoll
wenn man sagen infektion wirklich verhindern will muss man halt möglichst super schnell sein und eigentlich diesen einen kontakt überspringen gut der ist dann schon gewarnt aber wenn man sozusagen dann,
die kontakte der kontakte.
Quasi auch noch vor waren könnte in dem moment da ist dann zwar die wahrscheinlichkeit geringer aber so eigentlich kann man nur so effektiv den großteil der.
Infektionen verhindern weil wenn ich sage erst nach zehn oder elf tagen des des ganze melde dann sind sozusagen schon zwei generationen an infektionen gelaufen.
Na ja ich verstehe was du sagst aber die funktion die man jetzt dafür ermöglichen müsste die ist dann natürlich hoch problematisch weil das wäre ja dann sozusagen ein ich melde zwar nicht dass ich offiziell.
Virus habe sondern ich sag nur.
So und diese informationen gibt's dann an andere die das dann aber überhaupt nicht einzuordnen wissen weil die app irgendwie sowieso immer nur denselben dialog anzeigt so.
Buddy minus und dann werden sie alle trotzdem also was kannst du halt da nicht einbauen trotzdem kann man natürlich die turnaround zeit signifikant senken.
Im vergleich zu den traditionellen recherche methoden weil wie du ja schon richtig beschrieben hast wenn der normale weg jetzt ist
jemand im gesundheitsamt setzt sich dann hin und fängt an irgendwie deine leute die dir vielleicht irgendwie in dem moment auch gar nicht so richtig einfallen mit denen du vor fünf tagen zusammengesessen hast die du auch vielleicht gar nicht kennst.
Die sozusagen davon in kenntnis zu setzen das dauert ja dann nochmal wertvolle tage und am ende ist der gewinn des hat minus auch in der sendung schon so schön gesagt,
retten tust du sozusagen den zweiten hopp also sozusagen nicht die,
die unmittelbar notifiziert wird von deinem vorfall sondern eben die person die diese person treffen konnte und dahinter das ist sozusagen das was du aktiv schützt und damit natürlich indirekt auch alle
aber wenn du jetzt sagst ich krieg die notifiziert da steht drin vor fünf tagen könntest du das bekommen haben ja.
Und du weißt du hast vor fünf tagen in einem großen meeting mit irgendwie fuffzig leuten acht stunden gesessen so.
Dann kannst du da eben auch entsprechend darauf reagieren selbst wenn,
dein test dann auch noch nicht abgeschlossen ist also bevor du in der lage bist digital das wieder reinzukippen hast du zumindest unmittelbar sofort wenn das eigentliche erste testergebnis feststellt hast du schon mal anhaltspunkt hier,
donnerstag fuffzehn uhr kontakt mit einer person die es nachgewiesen ist du samstag und dann kannst du die leute anrufen und kann sagen hier,
tralala ich habe erfahren bringt euch mal in sicherheit weil weiß der geier also selbst wenn es digital nicht sofort weitergereicht werden kann ist trotzdem schon zeit gewonnen.
Aber dann können wir sozusagen festhalten wirklich helfen
infektionen zu vermeiden tut es nur wenn die person dann gleich auch unmittelbar alle mit denen sie in kontakt gewesen sein könnte benachrichtigt sowas ja,
in der regel auch passiert,
in der praxis wenn jemand das erfährt dass also das spricht sich halt halt ganz schnell rum aber dieser effekt sagen es halt wichtig alleine nur mit.
Denjenigen zu warnen da ist es wahrscheinlich eigentlich schon zu spät.
Es kann auch nur helfen ne also es ist nicht die universal lösung ne also das muss man auch mal wieder klar waren diese tracing apps sind nur ein weiterer baustein aber ist halt ein baustein der sich als ganz praktisch erweisen könnte das zumindest meine vermutung
wenn möglichst viele leute die daran teilnehmen ja im hinblick auf die geschwindigkeit so.
Ach so aber notifiziert ist noch noch noch mal ein guter punkt so wie ich das verfahren jetzt aber verstehe.
Kriegst du keine notifiziert in dem sinne sondern.
Du kriegst die von deiner app.
Deine app muss genau deine app muss in periodischen abständen.
Daten holen und dann überprüfen also es ist nicht so dass der server jetzt dass irgendein server dich
anruft oder dir eine notification schickt hier da war ein match weil das kann er nicht leisten sondern das kann nur die die app selber gut.
Also solche sachen werden auch diskutiert also dieser dieser pep standard der da vorgeschlagen ist der hat im prinzip zwei alternativen nämlich die reine.
Methode wie wie wir das jetzt besprochen haben weil das muss man noch dazu sagen für alle die jetzt durchgehend zugehört haben das was wir jetzt hier gerade beschreiben ist das szenario was ich ableitet.
Aus diesem expliziten apple google propose.
Ja also wir reden die ganze zeit nur von einer infrastruktur die exakt dieses modell nutzt und darauf eine eine app basieren lässt und richtig wie du sagst ne daraus leitet sich ab,
es gibt kein wissen über deine infektionen in diesem server.
Also es gibt kein wissen also der server weiß nicht mit wem der kontakt war und kann dementsprechend auch keine notifications machen alles was er sagt ist.
Hallo wir haben neue daten wollt ihr mal runterladen und dann kriegen die apps vielleicht eine notification im sinne
lad mal runter es gibt neue daten und dann kommen die auch relativ zeitnah drauf aber es gibt keine notification mit wir wissen dass du kontakt hattest ob du den kontakt hattest stellt deine app auf deinem telefon komplett nur dort isoliert
fest sagt dir dann ich habe da was gefunden das sieht für mich ein bisschen fischi aus kontakt länge sowieso datum sowieso und jetzt zieht eine schlüsse daraus.
Vielleicht noch so ein zwei andere sachen die mir noch so lose dazu einfallen jetzt auch konkret zu diesem propose.
Was ganz gutes finde ich ist es ist halt ein globaler ansatz.
Nichts nichts da drin ist in irgendeiner form reduziert und das macht meiner meinung nach auch extrem sinn das heißt selbst wenn wir hier eine nationale melde infrastruktur haben
wäre es durchaus vorstellbar,
dass wenn ich diese meldung durchgeführt habe und die daten an den deutschen tracing app server dann übermittelt über diesen weg ja das dann.
Der infrastruktur des der französischen tracing app die jetzt auf demselben technischen standards operiert.
Das mitteilt und diese kies dort auch noch hingibt sodass eben auch alle französischen app nutzer dieselbe information bekommen.
Weil es kann ja sein dass ich in frankreich war kann ja sein ich bin über die grenze gefahren pendler tralala ich war im urlaub ich bin unterwegs gewesen wir reden ja jetzt auch über eine zeit wo eben dieser ultimative lok down nicht mehr so.
Aufrecht erhalten wird wie es derzeit der fall ist das heißt es macht einfach sinn ein globalen standard zu haben der
universell funktioniert und wo man zwar eine nationale melde logik hat und da versucht sicherzustellen dass funktioniert ne ist natürlich in dem moment problematisch wo irgendein land das nicht richtig implementiert,
sag mal was weiß ich.
Ich bin jetzt kein land unterstellen dass sie das nicht hinbekommen aber ist ja durchaus vorstellbar ja dass dass das dort mit der meldung nicht funktioniert dann kann es natürlich durchaus sein dass diese tollerei und diese dieses flooding mit mit mit falschmeldungen irgendwie stattfindet aber auch da
gilt immer wieder.
Daraus kann kein kontakt entstehen wenn es nicht wirklich in kontakt gab's können zwar falsche daten da landen aber die führen nicht zur falschen meldungen weil du hast ja immer noch diese nicht du siehst ja nicht und von daher glaube ich ist das alles,
im rahmen aber es würde eben sinn machen auf diesem protokoll zu basieren weil's eben meiner meinung nach privatsphäre sichern ist.
Und genug informationen bietet um richtig handeln zu können und man kann halt damit schaffen eine,
globale infrastruktur zu machen so dass eben auch alles was grenzübergreifend ist abgedeckt ist ich denke an der stelle können wir das jetzt auch erstmal dabei belassen.
Oder also wir werden uns auf jeden fall auch nochmal darüber gedanken machen ich bin mir sicher da wird wenn noch einige debattenpunkte aufkommen wieder an der stelle auch nochmal betonen.
Ich habe mir das jetzt so angeschaut das ist mein verständnis davon ja mein mein wissen das nicht nicht unendlich groß und es mag durchaus sein dass hier noch ein paar aspekte aufkommen in dieser debatte die wir halt führen deswegen.
Reden wir ja jetzt auch darüber wie man auch noch bedenken muss dabei und,
gerade bei computern unsere software system gilt immer das ist meistens dann doch am ende immer noch ein bisschen komplizierter als man ursprünglich gedacht hat aber es ist auf jeden fall hilfreich,
wenn man schon mal alles auf einem sehr einfach zu verstehenden modell aufbaut und das ist so rein aus netzwerker sicht hier an dieser stelle glaube ich durchaus gegeben.
Wie weit es trägt wenn man dann sehen.
Also es ist zumindest nicht auf auf den ersten blick nicht kompletter unsinn so.
Das ist schon mal eine menge.
Würde ich schon mal sagen und hat durchaus gewisse chancen,
ja irgendwie zu funktionieren so und vielleicht sogar besser als wir denken,
im moment und insbesondere ich meine was ich gut finde ist an der lösung.
Dass damit eine globale lösung möglich ist kann funktionieren das ganze definitiv.
Japan jetzt gäbe es sicherlich in unserem notizen noch so ein paar sachen die man auch noch aufgreifen könnte aber ich würde das ehrlich gesagt jetzt erstmal auf die nächste woche verschieben weil da ist jetzt nichts wichtiges dabei was unbedingt aufgerollt werden muss.
Oder hast du noch irgendwas was du der welt noch mitteilen möchtest.
Also ich hatte vorhin ja sagen zwei gründe genannt als ich den faden verloren habe so warum anlass zur hoffnung besteht und sagen der,
ja der eine fall war ja das mit kontakt tracing eine ganze menge machen können der andere anlass.
Zur hoffnung ist dass wir immer mehr auch über verbreitungsgebiete erfahren das heißt dass wir wissen wo was sind die hauptinfektionsalter wege was sind die,
situationen in denen sich die meisten leute infizieren und
welche schutzmaßnahmen sind wirksam und welche nicht das heißt auch da haben wir dann in gewissen optimierungsprogramme wo ich die hoffnung habe dass wir.
Dadurch dann mit intelligenteren maßnahmen in der lage sind auch einen shutdown zu vermeiden sei es durch masken in bestimmten situationen wo wir wissen wo es.
Dass das die helfen dass es dann eine masken pflicht gibt sei es dass man eben.
Ganz klar anderes super spreding situationen einfach vermeidet und,
darüber vermeiden kann von shutdown zu shutdown zu kommen sondern dass wir dann einen modus haben auch darüber wo wir langfristig unter eins bleiben können das schöne ist ja.
Selbst wenn es uns gelingen würde langfristig nur bei null komma neun neun zu bleiben hätten wir gewonnen weil
selbst dann oder das ist null komma fünf sein selbst bei null komma neun fünf das ist dann das schöne
auch wieder umgekehrt von exponenten dass sich dann der virus tatsächlich auch tot läuft und die große hoffnung wäre ja.
Mutti wird wahrscheinlich von epi gelogen nicht geteilt aber,
saß also der ursprüngliche saß virus ist tot es gibt saß eins nicht mehr der virus ist ausgestorben.
Und gut ob das jetzt hier im fall von saß zwei auch realistisch oder erreichbar ist weiß ich nicht aber ich sage erstmal wenn's mit saß eins möglich war und.
Der virus muss ja also es gibt gibt einmal die bezeichnung von den sogenannten reservat horst das heißt irgendwo wieder leute oder typischerweise sind's halt tiere dann,
die halt diesen,
virus latent ständig in sich tragen und weder immunität entwickeln noch krank werden sondern einfach den nur den virus verbreiten so und da ist die frage.
Gibt es dann solche leute jetzt auch dann bei saß saß zwei oder wird es vielleicht wie bei
saß eins so sein dass das ding komplett von der oberfläche verschwindet und eigentlich.
Ich sag mal wenn.
Leute maximal jetzt zehn tage lass es zwanzig tage in einzelfällen ansteckend sind.
Und dann brauchst du nur zwanzig tage lang.
Jegliche ansteckung zu verhindern wenn zwanzig tage lang sich niemand neu ansteckt ist das virus tot.
Dann gibt es keine ausbreitung also nur ob das realistisch ist ob es vielleicht jetzt sich denn andere mutationen gibt oder wie gesagt reservat irgendwo entstehen.
Die wir nicht tot kriegen aber ja ich sehe es halt ich sehe deswegen die situation nicht allzu hoffnungslos an.
Genau die richtigen worte zum abschluss dieses podcasts pavel vielen dank.
Alles klar tim tschüss.
Und ja ich hoffe das war für euch auch ein bisschen erhellend wieder nächste woche machen wir hier wieder zahlen auf vision zwischendurch gibt's bei u k w noch ein paar updates aus anderen bereichen ich sage vielen dank fürs zuhören.